ओके सो आई थिंक आई एम लाइव
नाउ लेट मी वेरीफाई वंस प्लीज जस्ट वेट
गाइस जस्ट जस्ट
वेट ओके तो मैं यहां पर एक बार ओपन कर
लेता हूं हमारा
लाइव चलिए तो यस यस यार
[संगीत]
लाइव चलिए तो वी आर लाइव नाउ
एंड आज जाने देते हैं सबको बहुत ही शानदार
आज का सेशन होने वाला है तो जल्दी से बुला
लीजिए अपने दोस्तों को मित्रों को सबको
बुला लीजिए
फटाफट वेलकम एवरी बडी वेलकम टू क्लास 13
ऑफ फ्री बग बाउंट कोर्स आज बहुत कमाल की
चीजें होने वाली है सीखने वाले हैं करने
वाले हैं क्योंकि आज हम करने वाले हैं गिट
रकन
हैप्पी दिवाली हैप्पी दिवाली चलो भाई
हैप्पी दिवाली आपको भी हैप्पी दिवाली चलिए
अ गुड इवनिंग एवरीबॉडी एंड वेलकम टू द डे
13 ऑफ बग बाउंट फ्री कोर्स एंड आज का जो
सेशन है जो क्लास है
वो पहली 13 से पहले जो हमारी क्लास थी 12थ
उसी तरह से बहुत ही ज्यादा इनफॉर्मेटिव
प्रैक्टिकल एंड बहुत कुछ होने वाला है ठीक
है आज एक नए टॉपिक नई चीजें आप सीखेंगे बग
बाउंट के अंदर में एंड यकीन मानिए दिस इज
अ वेरी वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग थिंग एंड कई सारे
पीव प2 जो है आप इसके थ्रू फाइंड आउट कर
सकते हैं कई सारे जो क्रिटिकल बग्स हैं
क्रिटिकल वनबिल उसको रिपोर्ट कर सकते हैं
सेंसिटिव डाटा एक्सपोजर काफी सारे जो है
इसके थ्रू आप फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं ठीक
है सो जस्ट वेट एंड लेट्स सी
ओके हेलो हेलो हेलो गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग
सबको अ
चलिए चलिए चलिए तो आई थिंक हमें स्टार्ट
करना चाहिए सभी लोग एक बार लाइक ठोक दो
फटाक से एंड बस 30 लोग आए हैं अभी तो आज
कहां बिजी है सब यार आज सिर्फ 23 है ओनली
ऐसा
कैसे जल्दी जल्दी आ जाओ जल्दी आ
जाओ
चलिए सो आई होप गाइस आप सब जो है मैं ऐसा
उम्मीद करता हूं कि आप
सबने प्रीवियस टास्क को कंप्लीट करा ट्राई
हैक मी का जो मैंने आपको टास्क दिए वो भी
कंप्लीट करा है एंड नाउ वी कैन मूव ऑन
राइट सो फार इन इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग सब
डोमेन सब डोमेन टेकओवर सब डोमेन नरेशन
सेंसिट डटा जावास्क्रिप्ट से नाउ आई एम ऑन
गिट हब रेकन
राइट अरे क्यों भाई ऐसे क्यों बोल रहे हो
मत बोलो ऐसे नेपाली क्यों निकले यहां से
भाई कोई भी आके देख सकता है सेशन को सिर्फ
आपके लिए थोड़ी ना सबके लिए ये ऑल ओवर
वर्ल्ड के कोई भी आके देख सकते हैं
इंफॉर्मेशन एंड नॉलेज किसी रीजन एंड टाइम
बाउंड या फिर किसी पर्टिकुलर एरिया बाउंड
नहीं होती है वो सबके लिए अवेलेबल होनी
चाहिए राइट चलिए तो मैं पहले मशीन से
कनेक्ट करूंगा मेरे डिजिटल ओशियन पे जो
हमारा डेफॉक्स स् पेंटेस्ट मशीन है अगर
आपको नहीं पता अभी तक तो ये हमारा एक
क्लाउड बेस मशीन है जहां 4gb की मेमोरी बी
की एक एसएसडी हार्ड डिस्क लगी हुई है एंड
काफी फास्ट यहां पे बग बाउंट जो है इससे
परफॉर्म हो सकती है आपकी एंड अगर आपको
डिजिटल ओसन पे आके क्लाउड वीपीएस लेना है
तो आप डिस्क्रिप्शन में इस वीडियो के लिंक
है वहां रेफरल उससे आप जब करेक्ट साइन अप
करेंगे तो आपको $200 जो है मिलेगा दो
महीनों के लिए जो काफी ज्यादा होता है
बहुत भी आप बहुत ज्यादा यूज़ करेंगे तो भी
ये जल्दी खत्म नहीं होगा ठीक है तो आराम
से आप यूज कर सकते हैं राइट तो चलिए यहां
पे मशीन की मेरी आईपी आ चुकी है मैं इसको
कनेक्ट करूंगा मैं यहां पे आज नॉर्मल
विंडोज टर्मिनल यूज़ नहीं करूंगा आई विल
बी यूजिंग m एक्सटम मैंने आपको पहले ही
बताया था कि हम इसको यूज कर सकते हैं m
एक्सटम ठीक है यह सॉफ्टवेयर है मैं आपको
दिखा देता हूं यहां डेस्कटॉप पे पड़ा हुआ
है ये पोर्टेबल वर्जन मैंने डाउनलोड किया
हुआ है तो डायरेक्टली एग्जीक्यूट हो जाएगा
इंस्टॉल करने की जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी तो
मोबा एक्सटम को डायरेक्टली यहां पे डबल
क्लिक करके मैं इसको स्टार्ट कर सकता हूं
तो कुछ इस तरह का इंटरफेस आपको देखने को
मिल जाएगा मोबा एक्सटम का बहुत बढ़िया
इंटरफेस है यहां पे इस सामने फ्रंट
स्क्रीन पे आपको आपकी शेल मिल जाएगी
टर्मिनल मिल जाएगी लेफ्ट साइड में यहां पे
सारे फाइल्स जो आपके लोकल या रिमोट पे हैं
वो आपको विजिबल हो जाते हैं ठीक है चलिए
तो यहां पे आपको अगर एक एसएसएस सेशन हमें
स्टार्ट करना है ओबवियसली तो हमें क्या
करना है सेशंस पे जाना है सबसे पहले इस पे
आके एसएसएस चूज कर लेना है एसएसएस चूज
करेंगे यहां पे रिमोट होस्ट यानी जो आईपी
आपकी है आपके अ पेंटेस्ट बॉक्स की या फिर
आपके डिस्टल ओसन के बॉक्स की या क्लाउड की
अ मशीन की तो यहां पे आप मेंशन कर दीजिए
आईपी यहां पे आप यूजर नेम दे दीजिए रूट
यूजर नेम हमारा है एंड ओके पे प्रेस कर
दीजिए जैसे ही आप ओके प्रेस करते हैं यहां
आपका रूट का पासवर्ड मांगना अ मांगेगा एंड
आपको यहां पे कंट्रोल प्रेस करके माउस के
स्क्रॉल बटन को थोड़ा सा ऊपर स्क्रॉल
करेंगे तो इसकी फंट साइज इंक्रीज ऐसे हो
जाती है यहां मैं पासवर्ड दे देता हूं जो
मेरा पासवर्ड है बॉक्स का एंड
दैट्ची कर सकते हैं हम एंड कुछ इस तरीके
से आपको ये दिखना शुरू हो जाता है पहले की
जो फाइल्स हैं आप सबको यहां पे दिख गई
होंगी सो वी आर इन टू आवर बॉक्स ठीक है तो
हमारा यहां पे हु एम आई करेंगे तो
ओबवियसली आप रूट हैं प्रेजेंट वर्किंग
डायरेक्टरी आपकी स्ल रूट है यानी होम है
एंड
दैट्ची टॉपिक एक्चुअली है क्या ठीक है
क्या हम उसमें करने वाले हैं एक्चुअल में
हमें क्यों रिक्वायरमेंट है गब रेकन की
चलिए सबसे पहले हम इसको समझते हैं चलिए
मैं यहां पे एक ओपन करता हूं एक टेक्स्ट
बॉक्स एंड यहां पे मैं थोड़ा सा अ इसको
जूम इन कर लेता हूं 42 आर यर यहां पर हम
जो आज करने वाले हैं गिट हब रेकन करने
वाले हैं ठीक है नाउ गिट हब रिकन की जरूरत
क्यों पड़ती है मैं आपको सीधा-सीधा बहुत
ही सिंपल से एग्जांपल से समझाता हूं ठीक
है मान लो मेरी कंपनी है
f.com ठीक है मेरी कंपनी है फनि साइबर
सिक्योरिटी लेट्स सपोज डेनिक्स सपोज नहीं
है ही साइबर सिक्योरिटी यह मेरी कंपनी है
प्राइवेट लिमिटेड मेरी कंपनी का एक डोमेन
है de.com
ठीक है इस डोमेन में यहां पर मेरी बहुत
सारी सर्विसेस इस यहां पर मेरी बहुत सारी
सर्विसेस जो है वह चल रही है एंड मोस्ट ऑफ
द सर्विसेस या बहुत सारी सर्विसेस जो है
मेनी सर्विसेस
सर्विसेस सर्विसेस कोडस आर स्टोर्ड ऑन गिट
हब ऑन गिट हब गिट हब का मतलब है सिंपल
गिट प्लस
हब गिट रिपोजिटरीज का एक हब है जिसको हम
गिट हब बोलते हैं एंड गिट रिपोजिटरीज में
क्या होते हैं कोड्स होते हैं कंपनी के
अलग-अलग प्रोजेक्ट्स के अलग-अलग सर्विसेस
के जो भी उनका कोई प्रोडक्ट है या किसी
थर्ड पार्टी क्लाइंट के लिए बना रहे हैं
उसका जो भी कोडिंग्स होता है वो स्टोर
करने के लिए गिट हब का लोग जनरली यूज़
करते हैं डेवलपर्स यूज़ करते हैं ठीक है
अब देखो जब कोडिंग को स्टोर करने के लिए
कोई जगह पे तुम किसी कोड को स्टोर करोगे
तो दो दो चीजें हैं एक तो तुम नॉर्मली
उसको स्टोर कर दो बात वहां पे खत्म हो
जाती है दूसरी क्या होती है कि तुम जब कोड
स्टोर करोगे तो उसको सिक्योर भी करोगे ऐसा
नहीं कि अब तुमने कोई यूजर नेम पासवर्ड
कमेंट में लिख दिया मान लो ऐसा होता है
पॉस मतलब इट माइट बी पॉसिबल कि तुमने मतलब
तुमने
सॉरी तुमने यहां पे अ कुछ भी कोड किया और
पता चले कि यहां पे तुमने क्या किया यहां
पे पासवर्ड अ पासवर्ड
इज हिंट पासवर्ड ऐसे तुमने एक पासवर्ड डाल
दिया ये एक तुमने कमेंट कर दिया बेसिकली
कमेंट आउट कर दिया अब तुम्हें लग रहा है
कि तुमने क्या किया कमेंट किया गिट हब के
एक रिपोजिटरी के अंदर किया गिट हब के अंदर
एक रिपोजिटरी है उसके अंदर तुमने कुछ
कोड्स लिखे उसमें एक कमेंट वाली लाइन डाल
दी कि कौन यहां पहुंच रहा है यार कौन इस
पासवर्ड को खोज रहा है बट अब ये जो
पासवर्ड है ये किसके लिए है फॉर यूजर
एडमिन इस एडमिन के लिए ये पासवर्ड है एंड
कैन बी एक्सेस्ड
फ्रॉम एंड यहां पे तुमने कुछ कोड यहां पे
तुमने कुछ दे दिया एटीटीपी कॉलन
127.0
0.0.1 एडमिन मान लो दिस इज एग्जांपल लिंक
ये रियल लिंक नहीं है दिस इज एन एग्जांपल
लिंक अब तुमने ये कर दिया कि पासवर्ड इज
हिंट पासवर्ड ये तुम्हारे गिट हब
रिपोजिटरी के ये गब रेपो कोड है रेपो के
अंदर एक कोड है जिसमें तुमने इस तरीके से
कुछ कोड किया है ये आपका टिपिकल कोड हो
गया एंड ये आपका एक कमेंट हो गया पासवर्ड
इज हिंट पासवर्ड फॉर यूजर एडमिन कैन बी
एक्सेस्ड फ्रॉम ये ये तुमने उसमें डाल
दिया अब मान लो तुम्हें तो लग रहा है यार
कौन सी बड़ी बात है क्या हो गया ये तो
हमारा ही मैं कोड लिख रहा हूं मेरा गिट हब
रिपोजिटरी है मैंने उसको रखा हुआ है अपने
रिपोजिटरी में कंपनी के सिंपल सी फ सिंपल
सा फंडा है लेकिन एक एथिकल हैकर एक
सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चर एक बग बाउंट हंटर आपकी
तरह हमारी तरह क्या करेगा गिट हब रेक ऑन
कर रहा होगा गिट रेकन करके वो एक टारगेट
चूज करेगा टारगेट में चूज करेगा de.com
ठीक है चलिए अब ये देखेगा कि fan.com के
गिट हब रिपोजिटरीज हैं प्रेजेंट या नहीं
है इसके लिए वो गिट हब के कुछ डॉक्स का
इस्तेमाल करेगा गिट हब के क्या करेगा
डॉक्स का इस्तेमाल करेगा किस तरह का डॉक
इस्तेमाल करेगा तो क्या करेगा सिंपली गिट
हब पे जाएगा कुछ इस तरीके से अपने अकाउंट
से लॉगइन कर लेगा मैं ऑलरेडी लॉग इन हूं
कुछ इस तरीके से गट पे चला जाएगा
github.com पे यहां पे सर्च का ऑप्शन आता
है सर्च पे जाएगा यहां सर्च करेगा
नक् क आप इसको डबल कोट में भी रख सकते हैं
अदर वाइज यू कैन जस्ट लीव इट तो यहां पे
मैं अगर डबल कोट में रख देता हूं इस तरीके
से ये इस तरह से करेगा और यहां पे सर्च
करेगा
पासवर्ड ये कीवर्ड डालेगा एक एक
googleupdate.exe अगर उन रिजल्ट्स में वो
स्पेसिफिक जो रिपोजिटरी है उसमें जो कोड
है अगर वोह विजिबल हो जा रहे हैं या आ जा
रहे हैं यहां पे रिजल्ट्स में आपको दिख जा
रहे हैं तो वो पासवर्ड जो यहां पे वो बंदा
पासवर्ड दे रखा है यह कोड उसको मिल जाएगा
एंड यहां पे यह पासवर्ड उसको मिल जाएगा इस
पर्टिकुलर डॉक की मदद से एंड आराम से उस
यूआरएल पे जाके यह पासवर्ड यूज करके एडमिन
यूजर एडमिन एज अ यूजर ऐड करके और वो लॉग
इन करके आपके पर्टिकुलर फाइल को एक्सेस कर
पाएगा या ऐसे सेंसिटिव लोकेशन को एक्सेस
करेगा या एंटर कर जाएगा जहां बेसिकली उसको
नहीं करना चाहिए वो सिर्फ ऑथेंटिकेटेड
यूजर्स के लिए होना चाहिए ठीक
है
ओके यस समझ में आ रहा है आप लोगों को अ
एवरीवन गेटिंग प्लीज आप लोग प्लीज आप लोग
वो मत
कीजिएगा स्पैम मत कीजिएगा अदर वाइज आपको
मुझे बैन करना पड़ जाएगा ठीक है तो इस
तरीके से वो क्या करेगा क्रेडेंशियल फाइंड
कर लेगा इतना तो आपको समझ में आ गया होगा
ठीक है इट्स वेरी इजी थिंग चलिए अब यहां
तो हमने क्या किया यहां पे हमने क्या किया
मेरा यहां पे मैं चलता हूं यहां पे सिंपल
गिट अप पे फिर से यहां पे चलते हैं ठीक है
एंड अब क्या करते हैं यहां पे ये हमने
पासवर्ड यहां पे कर दिया ठीक है अब di.com
पासवर्ड अब यहां पे कोई एक और कीवर्ड डाल
सकता है वो एआई अ की ये भी एक कीवर्ड है
अब फिर से एंटर करेगा अगर एपीआई की से
रिलेटेड कुछ मिलती है f.com का कुछ भी
व्हाट एवर तो वो यहां पे फिर से रिफ्लेक्ट
होगा एंड उसको मिल जाएगा अभी फिलहाल कुछ
भी यहां पे नहीं रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा है
क्योंकि कुछ ऐसा रिपोजिटरी अवेलेबल नहीं
है ये बस एग्जांपल के लिए है अब देखिए ये
जो
google.com और एक एआई की तो ये जो
कॉ है इसको हम बोलेंगे कीवर्ड कीवर्ड एंड
यह जो एपीआई की
है इसको हम बोलेंगे डॉक जो एक्चुअली डॉक
है आपका ठीक है इतना समझ में आ रहा आप
लोगों को कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है जरा बता
दीजिए मुझे एवरीवन गेटिंग इतना समझ में आ
रहा है ना भाई कोई दिक्कत तो नहीं आ रही
है ठीक
है भाई सीखने से मतलब रखो यह रियल फेक से
प्लीज अगर आपको रियल फेक वाले में रहना है
तो फिर उसी में रहो कोई बात नहीं सीखने से
मतलब रखो रियल पर भी आएंगे ना अभी तक तो
सब रियल ही होता है थोड़ा पेशेंस रखा करो
और ध्यान दिया करो ठीक है चीजों
प तो ओके डि कॉ यहां पर कीवर्ड दे दिया
ओके ग्रेट अब यहां पर यह कीवर्ड हो गया यह
डॉक हो गया तो इस तरीके से गिट हब रेकन आप
करते हैं अब यहां पर बात करते हैं गिट हब
रेकन के बारे में तब जब हम बात करते हैं
तो गिट हब रेकन
को गिट हब रिकॉन को दो तरीके से किया जा
सकता है एक ऑटोमेटेड वे से और दूसरा जो है
वह मैनुअल वे से दो तरीके से ऑटोमेटेड वे
में डिफरेंट टूल्स आर यूज्ड यहां पर
अलग-अलग टूल्स यूज होते हैं मैनुअल वे में
मैनुअल ह्यूमन
अप्रोच ह्यूमन अप्रोच होते हैं ठीक है ओके
समझ में आ
गया आयू गेमर इनको मुझे टाइम आउट करना
पड़ेगा मजबूरी है कुछ नहीं कर सकते सॉरी
आयू गेमर
ब्रदर मैं आपको टाइम आउट कर रहा हूं
नेक्स्ट 24 घंटे के लिए ताकि आप डिस्टर्ब
ना करें ठीक
है ओके तो मैनुअल ह्यूमन अप्रोच दो तरीके
से हैं हम दोनों तरीका देखने वाले हैं
ऑटोमेटेड भी और मैनुअल भी बट इन दोनों में
बेस्ट कौन सा है यह है हमारा मैनुअल
अप्रोच सबसे बेस्ट एंड सबसे ज्यादा लाइक
काइंड ऑफ आप बोल सकते हैं कि जो एकदम
फोकस्ड आपको रिजल्ट देता है लेस फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव्स देता है एंड आपको बेहतर रिजल्ट
देता है यह है मैनुअल अप्रोच ऑटोमेटेड
टूल्स जो है ना इसमें बहुत तरह की
दिक्कतें आती है हालांकि टूल्स आपको यूज
करने हैं ऐसा मैं नहीं बोल रहा कि नहीं
करने हैं टूल्स यूज करके थोड़े बहुत कुछ
पॉसिबल गिट हब रिपोजिटरी फाइंड करके देन
उसमें आप मैनुअल सर्च कर सकते हैं लेकिन
सबसे बढ़िया वे आपका मैनुअल ही होता है
सबसे बढ़िया वे मैनुअल होता है चलिए ठीक
है अब यहां पे हम दोनों वे देखने वाले हैं
दोनों चीज करने वाले हैं बट उसके पहले
सबसे पहले हम क्या करेंगे एक हम अपना
टारगेट चूज करेंगे टारगेट यूज करने के लिए
आप सबको पता ही है बहुत सारा बहुत इजी है
b.com पे जाइए ठीक
है अ शांके लेट हो गया कोई बात नहीं शांके
जस्ट स्टार्टेड ओके सो बक राउड पे आते हैं
एंड यहां प्रोग्राम्स पे चलते हैं एंड एक
टारगेट को चूज कर लेते हैं लेट्स सिलेक्ट
टारगेट कोई भी एक रिसेंट टारगेट ही चूज कर
लेते हैं रैपिड हमारा टारगेट था ही ऑलरेडी
तो रैपिड को ही हम सेलेक्ट कर लेते हैं
हमारा ऑलरेडी टारगेट था हमारा रैपिड पहले
भी हमने यूज़ किया इसको तो रैपिड के हम
स्कोप में आ जाते हैं यहां पर आप देख सकते
हैं बहुत ही बहुत ही इथ स्कोप है डोमेन सब
डोमेन सारे इसमें इंक्लूडेड है rapid.com
वे देखने वाले हैं सबसे पहले ऑटोमेशन
देखेंगे फिर मैनुअल देखेंगे या फिर मैनुअल
देखे फिर ऑटोमेटेड देखें जैसा आपकी जैसा
आप बोले चलिए मैनुअली देख लेते हैं पहले
ठीक है सबसे पहले मैनुअल वे देखते हैं
मैनुअल वे के अंदर क्या होता है आपके पास
एक अच्छी कीवर्ड लिस्ट होनी चाहिए परफेक्ट
बढ़िया कीवर्ड लिस्ट जितने ज्यादा कीवर्ड
लिस्ट आपके पास होंगे आप उनको मैनुअली जो
है यूज कर सकते हैं वेरीफाई कर सकते हैं
बहुत सारी चीजें कर सकते हैं ठीक है एंड
सर्च आउट कर सकते हैं तो अब हमारे पास एक
टारगेट है
r.net सॉरी
रड नेट अब हम क्या करते हैं मैनुअल वे
हमारा स्टार्ट करते हैं एंड देखिए मैनुअल
वे हम कैसे क्या क्या चीजें कर सकते हैं
देखिए अब हमें खोजना क्या है सबसे पहली
बात तो हमें खोजना क्या है जैसे कि पहले
हमने ट्राई सर्च किया था यह कुछ कीवर्ड
सर्च किए थे सेम वही कीवर्ड्स उसी तरह के
कीवर्ड सर्च करते हैं सेंसिटिव डाटा फाइंड
करने हैं हमारा मेन मोटिव यही होना चाहिए
कुछ भी ऐसा सेंसिटिव जो आप रिपोर्ट कर
सकते जिस पर आपको बाउंट या आपको रिवॉर्ड
स्वाग वगैरह मिल सकता है राइट चलिए जैसे
एड्स की ठीक है एडब्ल्यू एस सीक्रेट एपीआई
की पासवर्ड पास
डब्ल्यूडीटीटी पी पासवर्ड डेटाबेस से
रिलेटेड कोई कोई इंफॉर्मेशन हो एडमिन से
रिलेटेड कोई इंफॉर्मेशन हो एसटी एक्सेस से
रिलेटेड कोई इंफॉर्मेशन डट गट से रिलेटेड
नवी से रिलेटेड ड गट इग्नोर से रिलेटेड या
एक्सेस की कुछ भी हो हमें फाइंड करना है
अब हमारे पास एक ना कीवर्ड्स की लिस्ट
होनी चाहिए तो चलिए मैं आपको यहां पर
कीवर्ड की लिस्ट दिखाता
हूं
अ गब के डॉक्स की लिस्ट हमारे पास एक
बेसिकली कीवर्ड के लिस्ट की बात यहां पे
जो मैं कर रहा हूं वो गिट हब के डॉक्स की
बात कर रहा हूं ठीक है और कुछ भी नहीं गिट
हब डॉक्स हमें चाहिए अब गिट हब डॉग्स आपको
बहुत सारे मिल जाएंगे मेरे पास कुछ लिस्ट
है गिट हब डॉग्स के आप उनको यूज कर सकते
हैं बहुत अच्छे लिस्ट्स है आपको इंटरनेट प
वैसे बहुत सारे मिल जाएंगे तो मैं यहां पे
आपको दिखा देता हूं ये कुछ लिंक्स है जो
मैंने रखे हुए हैं गिब डॉक्स के अब मान लो
मैं एक कोई सा भी डॉक ओपन कर लेता हूं
लेट्स सपोज यह वाला लास्ट वाला ओपन कर
लेता हूं तो यह आपको ग डॉक की लिस्ट यहां
पे मिल जाती है ये देखिए आपको ये गिट हब
डॉक्स की यहां पे लिस्ट मिल जाती है ये
फाइल नेम कुछ ऐसे करके कुछ इस तरीके से आ
रहा है चलिए और भी कुछ लिस्ट निकाल लेते
हैं एक ये
रहा जी हां तो इस तरीके से आपको गिट हब
डॉक्स की पूरी लिस्ट मिल जाती है जब मैं
इसको रॉ पे विजिट करूंगा तो आपको कंप्लीट
यहां पे दिख जाएगा इसको थोड़ा मैं जूम इन
अगर करूंगा तो आपको यहां पे ये जूम इन
होके दिख जाएगा ठीक है एक्सेस की एक्सेस
टोकन एक्सेस टोकन एक्सेस टोकन ऐसे कुछ इस
तरीके से आपको ये डॉग्स मिल जाएंगे बहुत
सारे डॉग्स हैं यहां पे आप सारे डॉग्स के
लिए सर्च कर सकते सकते हैं मैनुअल सर्चिंग
कर सकते हैं गिट हब रिकॉर्न में आपके
पेशेंस की बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है पेशेंस
अगर रखते हैं तो यकीन मानिए यू विल गेट
समथिंग वेरी वेरी क्रिटिकल सम डे एंड आप
उसको रिपोर्ट करेंगे और वो वैलिड भी होगा
ठीक
है कोई बात नहीं शालिस नो नॉट एन इशू कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है आप लोग आए बहुत अच्छी बात
है जो लेट आए हैं कोई बात नहीं है अभी
स्टार्ट ही हुआ है एंड आप लोग आए यही बहुत
बड़ी बात है मुझे अच्छा लगता है जो लोग
लाइव अटेंड कर रहे हैं सेशन को मुझे पता
है जितने लोग लाइव अटेंड कर रहे हैं जो भी
60-70 लोग हैं आई कैन एश्योर कि इन्हीं
60-70 लोग में से या फिर जो सिंसियर कर
रहे हैं ना व ही कुछ करेंगे आगे चलके
स्पेशली इन बग बाउंट एंड मैं यकीन के साथ
कह सकता हूं कि दे विल फाइंड अ वैलिड बग
हंट करेंगे व वैलिड बग भी निकालेंगे एंड
लिंक न पे जब टैग करेंगे तो मैं उसको
रीपोस्ट करूंगा मैं उसको पोस्ट करूंगा जब
उनको कोई बाउंटीज या स्वैग या कुछ भी मिल
जाता है या कोई वैलिड बग ही मिल जाता है
कोई रिवॉर्ड ना मिले तो भी जब आप टैग
करोगे हमारी कंपनी को या मुझे तो मैं उसको
रीपोस्ट करूंगा एंड आई विल फील मोर प्राउड
देन यू एक्चुअल में ठीक है सो जस्ट कीप इट
ऑन आप लगे रहो एंड पेशेंस लेवल आपका चेक
करता है बक बाउंट याद रखिएगा जितना पेशेंस
आपके पास होगा उतने अच्छी रिवॉर्ड आपको
मिलेगी अगर आप हरबड़ा जाएंगे घबरा जाएंगे
सोचेंगे अरे यार अब कुछ नहीं मिल नहीं रहा
तो फिर वहां आपके लिए बग बाउंट है ही नहीं
सो अपने अंदर हिम्मत लाइए पेशेंस लाइए एंड
टाइम दीजिए एक पर्टिकुलर टारगेट को जितना
टाइम देंगे आप टारगेट को उतनी ज्यादा
अच्छी रिवॉर्ड मिलने के चांसेस आपको मिल
जाते हैं ठीक है
चलिए
चलिए तो यहां पे ये सारे आपके अ गिट हब के
डॉग्स हैं इन सबको अब देखो क्या होता है
टूल्स क्या करते हैं मैं आपको बता देता
हूं सिंपल सा लॉजिक समझा देता हूं टूल्स
इन सारे डॉक्स को जो आप मैनुअली सर्च
करोगे ना वो आपको ऑटोमेटिक सर्च कर कर के
रिजल्ट दे देंगे बस यही काम होगा लेकिन
टूल्स के अंदर रेट लिमिट का दिक्कत आता है
ठीक है प्रॉक्सीस बैन होने का दिक्कत आता
है गिट हब रिपोजिटरी को क्लोन करने में
डाटा कंजप्शंस होते हैं स्टोरेज का बहुत
सारा दिक्कत है ये सारी और लास्ट में
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स आपको मिलते हैं जब आप
ऑटोमेटिक टूल्स यूज़ करेंगे यू विल गेट
मेनी फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स बिकॉज़ ऑफ द रिजेक्स
इश्यूज बिकॉज़ ऑफ द एंट्रॉपिज इश्यूज एंड
बहुत सारी दिक्कतें होती हैं उसके कारण से
आपको फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स मिलते हैं ठीक है
मतलब आपको मिलना चाहिए कुछ और उसी के बरा
उसी के तरह कुछ दिखता हुआ आपको टोकन दिखाई
दे रहा है वो बोलेगा कि यही टोकन है जबकि
वो एक्चुअल टोकन होगा नहीं उसका आप यूज़
नहीं कर सकते उसका कोई इंपैक्ट आप दिखा
नहीं सकते टारगेट के ऊपर तो फिर इस तरीके
के फॉल्स पॉज बट आप जब मैनुअल करते हैं ना
जब ह्यूमन इंटरेक्शन होता है व सबसे बेस्ट
एंड सबसे स्लो तो होता है बट सबसे बेस्ट
एंड सबसे एक्यूरेट होता है तो मैनुअल
अप्रोच गिट हब रकॉन में स्पेशली जब आप गिट
हब रकॉन करते हैं जावास्क्रिप्ट रिकॉर्न
करते हैं इसमें सबसे बेस्ट अप्रोच मैनुअल
होता है बाकी चीजों में टूल्स आपके काम
करेंगे टूल्स अच्छे होते हैं बट इन सब में
आपका मैनुअल बेस्ट होता है आप यू शुड
ऑलवेज गो विद द मैनुअल अप्रोच अ मोस्ट
प्रोबेबली ठीक है मैं ऑलवेज मैनुअल अप्रोच
ही यूज़ करता हूं बाकी ऑटोमेटिक टूल्स
बहुत कम यूज़ होते हैं इसमें चलिए
अब यहां पे कीवर्ड्स कैसे डिफाइन करना है
देखिए मैं यहां पे दिखाता हूं यहां पे
जैसे गिट रकन में
आपको इस तरीके के कुछ कीवर्ड्स डिफाइन
करके आप सर्च कर सकते हैं जैसे आपका
टारगेट एक पहले तो आपको टारगेट मेंशन करना
है ठीक है उसके बाद आपको वो पर्टिकुलर जो
डॉर्क है वो आपको मेंशन करना है बस
दैट्ची मेरे
पास हां यह आ गई हमारे पास ठीक है अब यहां
पे मुझे सर्च करना है किसके लिए डड n के
लिए हमारा जो टारगेट है रड नेट है तो मैं
क्या करता हूं रप नेट यहां पे एंटर कर
देता हूं मैं इसको डबल कोट में डाल देता
हूं इट्स अ गुड थिंग अगर आप डबल कोट में
डाल देते हैं तो अच्छी बात है ना भी डाले
तो काम चल ही जाएगा बट ठीक है मैं आपको
यहां पे डबल कोट में डालते हैं एंड यहां
पे हम कोई सा भी एक डॉक उठा लेते हैं जैसे
कि मैं उठाता हूं यहां पे एक्सेस टोकन
सीक्रेट नहीं ये देखो एक और चीज है
amazonbusiness.in यूजर को या तो इनफॉर्म
कर दे रहे हैं या तो उस चीज को ब्लॉक ही
कर दे रहे हैं ऐसा हमारे साथ भी हुआ हमारा
भी कुछ रिपोजिटरी अ था तो उसमें एडब्ल्यू
सीक्रेट जो टोकन हमने वैसे ही जस्ट
टेस्टिंग के लिए डाल दिया था सीक्रेट की
वहां पे एडब्ल्यू का मेल आ गया था हमारे
पास कि आपका एक्सपोज है कि अ इस पर्टिकुलर
रिपोजिटरी में आप उसको या तो हटाओ या तो
आपका ब्लॉक करना पड़ेगा हमारा ए मतलब इतनी
ज्यादा सिक्योरिटी है कुछ इस तरीके की
चीजें काम इस तरीके से अब मतलब चीजें हो
रही है बैकग्राउंड के अंदर में बट आपको
नहीं पता चलेगा बट हो रही है तो कुछ-कुछ
ऐसे कीवर्ड्स या डॉग्स आपको लाने पड़ेंगे
जो बहुत ज्यादा कॉमन नहीं अनकॉमन है थोड़ा
सा उसको आपको सर्च करना पड़ेगा देन यू कैन
गेट समथिंग बट वही है कि आप जब नॉर्मल
डॉक्स को भी सर्च करेंगे तो आपको उससे
रिलेटेड चीजें भी मिल सकती है एंड यू कैन
गेट सम सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन आल्सो राइट
चलिए सर मैं सर आज मैं
अ सर मैं डेली आपके लाइव को फॉलो करता हूं
और सारे टास्क करता हूं आपको टैग भी करता
हूं दिव्यांश और मैं इसको अच्छे से हां
दिव्यांश आई नो यू टैग ग गुड इवनिंग गौरव
बहुत
बढ़िया जिसका रेपो नहीं है मान लो किसी का
कोड बेस नहीं है गिट अप पे तो कुछ नहीं कर
सकते यार कॉमन सेंस है ना मतलब कॉमन सेंस
है ना यार जिसका घर ही नहीं है उसके
एड्रेस प कैसे पहुंच जाओगे भाई है ना यही
बात है ना सर आज मैं बहुत खुश हूं पता
नहीं मेरा डांस करने का मन कर रहा है आज
तक मुझे बहुत कुछ मिला है और आज तो मैं
इतना कुछ हूं कि क्या बताऊं मैं शांके डे
फोनिक्स ने लाइफ में एक वैल्यू प्रोवाइड
की है थैंक यू अ शांके फॉर दिस वंडरफुल
वर्ड्स वर्ड्स अ मींस अ लॉट टू अस पूरे
डिफर टीम के लिए काफी अच्छा अ काफी अच्छा
है कि आपको कुछ वैल्यूज मिल रही है
राइट चलिए अब मुझे यहां पे मान लो मैं एक
चीज सर्च करता हूं सबसे पहले बहुत ही कॉमन
चीज सर्च कर लेता हूं दैट दैट इज कॉमन चीज
क्या होती है पासवर्ड होती है चलिए इसमें
देखिए पासवर्ड भी होगा शायद होगा ही होगा
ओबवियसली बट दैट इज अ वेरी सिंपल थिंग ये
देखिए पासवर्ड पास
पासवर्ड सर्च कर लेते हैं तो यहां पे हम
आते हैं सॉरी यहां पे ऐड आ रहा है तो मैं
इसको थोड़ा सा स्किप कर देता हूं हां जी
तो यहां पे हमने सर्च किया पासवर्ड
दैट्ची कर लिया ये आपको अब देखो पासवर्ड
जब सर्च किया ना तो अब इसमें क्या कर सकते
हैं हमने पहले तो एक
rapid7 रिजल्ट्स आपको मिले हैं दैट इज अ
वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग थिंग कोड पे आप जाएंगे
अब कोड पे जब जाएंगे आप तो यहां
पे आपको
इंफॉर्मेशन मिले कोई यूजर नेम मिल जाए
पासवर्ड मिल जाए कोई सेंसिटिव लोकेशन या
आईपी एड्रेस मिल जाए कोई सेंसिटिव सब
डोमेन मिल जाए कोई डिफॉल्ट लॉगिन मिल जाए
कोई भी चीज मिल जाए तो आप रिपोर्ट करने से
पहले यह जरूर कंफर्म कर लीजिए कि वो जो
पर्टिकुलर सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन है वो इसी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन से बिलोंग करता है
से रिलेटेड है बट
rapid.com
ओए ओके ओके तो यहां पे हमें कुछ फाइल्स
मिली
है बट यह फाइल्स जेनरिक अ जेनरिक फाइल है
एक ड कपो . आई डोंट थिंक इसमें कुछ आपको
मिलेगा एपीआई एडमिन एपीआई की टेस्ट एडमिन
जेडटी सीक्रेट सीक्रेट मास्टर एंक्रिप्शन
की यहां पे एक मास्टर एंक्रिप्शन की है बट
आई डोंट थिंक की अ बिकॉज़ इट्स हां ये
टेस्ट एडमिन ये टेस्ट एडमिन है अब देखो
यहां पे ये देखा ना रिकॉर्न टेस्ट एडमिन
यहां टेस्ट लिखा हुआ है यानी कि टेस्ट
वाला जो है ना ये इंक्लूड किया हुआ है
टेस्ट जो क्रेडेंशियल है वो टेस्ट वाले है
ये आपका जेनरिक जो है ना यूनिक वाला
यूआरएल या कुछ ऐसा कुछ सीक्रेट की नहीं है
टेस्टिंग के लिए बनाया इन्होंने उसको बस
यहां डाल दिया तो उससे आप कुछ नहीं कर
पाओगे तो ऐसे जब कीवर्ड करो तो पासवर्ड
यहां लिखा है तो नॉट को यूज किया करो नॉट
एन ओटी नॉट मतलब हटा देना है ठीक है अब
नॉट के बाद क्या मुझे टेस्ट वाले हटा देने
रिजल्ट अब एंटर करते
हैं लेट्स सी अब देखिए जब हमने टेस्ट वाला
हटाया नोट करके तो अब आपका रिजल्ट देखिए
सिर्फ कोड में आठ आ रहे हैं ओनली एट देखा
कोड फिल्टर हो गया आपका सिंपल फिल्टरिंग
आपने लगा दी नॉट टेस्ट मतलब टेस्ट वाले
सारे हटा दो तो आ गया यहां पे अब एक और
चीज आती है एग्जांपल होता है बहुत सारा तो
नॉट नॉट
एग्जांपल एग्जांपल वाले रिजल्ट भी हटा
देने हैं शायद और फिल्टर हो जाए लेट्स
सी यहां सिर्फ छह आ रहे हैं यानी अब सिर्फ
बचे कितने छह बचे
दैट्ची मोर अ शॉर्टेड रिजल्ट्स सो आपको
ज्यादा चांसेस है एक वैलिड कुछ सेंसिटिव
इंफॉर्मेशन मिलने का चलिए जैसे हमें यहां
मिला है कुछ अ दिस इज आल्सो लाइक डब
rapid.com
अ दिस इज समथिंग रिलेटेड टू आप यहां पर
देख रहे
[संगीत]
हैं यू कैन फाइंड योर रैपिड पेमेंट कीज इन
योर यहां पर ये डेवलपर क्रेडेंशियल
रिलेटेड कुछ है चीजें बट ठीक है हम देख
लेते हैं कुछ यहां पर मिलता है कि नहीं
मिलता है ओके
ओके लेट्स सी लेट्स गो डाउन लेट्स गो डाउन
लेट्स गो
डाउन ी फाइंड
समथिंग नहीं कुछ भी नहीं है
नथिंग या अ देर इज नो हां याद रखिएगा जब
गिट हब रिपोजिटरी कोड्स चेक कर रहे हैं ना
तो कोड्स के अंदर आपको कुछ यूनिक सब डोमस
भी मिल सकते हैं जो आपको यूजुअली सब डोमेन
न्यूमरेशन में नहीं मिलेगा कुछ आईपी
एड्रेस डिस्क्लोज हो सकती है जो ऐसी आईपी
एड्रेस है जिसपे आप जाएंगे सीधा लॉग इन
कोई क्रेडेंशियल ही नहीं एक ऐसी आईपी
एड्रेस मिल सकती है जिस पे आप जैसे ही
जाएंगे विजिट करेंगे एडमिन एडमिन से लॉगिन
हो जाएगा डिफॉल्ट यूजरनेम पासवर्ड से
लॉगइन हो जाएगा एडमिन पासवर्ड से लॉगइन हो
जाएगा रूट रूट से लॉगइन हो जाएगा या फिर
टेस्ट सेट्स टेस्ट से लॉगइन हो जाएगा ऐसा
भी आपको फाइंड करना है सिर्फ आपको यहां
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन सिर्फ स्ट्रिंग्स
फाइंड नहीं करनी आपको ऐसी भी चीजें मिल
सकती हैं तो हर एक चीज़ के लिए ध्यान
दीजिएगा ठीक है नाउ वी कैन अ सी हियर वी
कैन वी कैन वी कैन वी कैन सी य नथिंग इज़
हियर राइट कुछ है नहीं यहां पे तो हमने
यहां पे नॉट लगा के फिल्टर कर लिया
एग्जांपल एंड ऑल कुछ खास हमें यहां पे
मिला नहीं है
निकालते
हैं
अ एक्सेस टोकन सीक्रेट लेट्स फाइंड दिस वन
एक्सेस टोकन सीक्रेट एंड अगेन नॉट हम यूज़
करेंगे क्योंकि हमें टेस्ट और एग्जांपल
वाले बिल्कुल भी नहीं चाहिए मुझे उससे कोई
मतलब नहीं है एक्सेस टोकन सीक्रेट से
रिलेटेड कुछ चीजें फाइंड करते हैं लेट्स
सी इफ वी आर गेटिंग समथिंग सो देयर इज
नथिंग कुछ भी नहीं है ओके कोई बात नहीं
कुछ भी नहीं है नॉट एन इशू कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है कुछ और करते हैं एपीआई कीज फाइंड
कर लेते हैं अ लाइक काइंड ऑफ दिस वन एपीआई
की लेट्स फाइंड
आउट देयर इज एपीआई
की एंड लेट्स सी इफ यू आर गेटिंग सम
रिजल्ट्स या हमें सिर्फ एक मिला है
क्योंकि हमने बहुत सारा फिल्टर लगा रखा है
ना तो यहां पे एक रिजल्ट हमें मिला है बट
रैपिड सैंपल एक्सेप्ट पेमेंट्स ठीक है
लेट्स सी हां तो यहां पे हमें कुछ मिला
क्या मिला योर एपीआई की ठीक है ये कोई लीक
नहीं है ट्स अ सिंपल कोड लीकेज नहीं यहां
पे पोर्ट 5000 यहां पे आपको दिख रहा है बस
और कुछ भी नहीं है ठीक है चलो अब यहां पे
एक चीज और आपको समझनी है जैसे आपको एक और
रिजल्ट मिला है ना यह वाली अ यह वाली इसको
ओपन कर लेते हैं ठीक है लेट्स ओपन इट यह
फॉक हुआ है इससे बढ़िया अब यह जो यूजर है
यह यूजर है इस पे आपको क्लिक करना है यह
यूजर आपको मिला ठीक है नीचे आते हैं यहां
पे कुछ डिटेल्स है आपके इसके पास कोई ऐसा
कुछ खास डिटेल यहां पे नहीं है ठीक है नॉट
मच ऑफ द डिटेल्स
या बट इस यूजर को क्या करना है ना जैसे
आपको कोई भी रिपोजिटरी मिलती है उस
रिपोजिटरी में कोई पर्टिकुलर यूजर कोई
पर्टिकुलर जो यूजर है वो क्या है डेवलपर
हो सकता है उस पर्टिकुलर कंपनी के लिए काम
कर सकता है यह मैं आपको मेथड एक लाइक सेंस
ऑफ थिंकिंग आपको समझा रहा हूं कि कैसे आप
सोच सकते हैं चीजों के लिए ठीक
है समझ में आ कैसे आप सोच सकते हैं तो अब
यह यूजर क्या है एक डेवलपर उस कंपनी के
लिए काम कर सकता है तो आप इस यूजर को फॉलो
कर सकते हैं इस यूजर को इसके पर्टिकुलर
वर्किंग के लिए फॉलो कर सकते हैं लाइक ये
क्या-क्या चीजें करता है किस तरीके से
कहां-कहां कोड्स लिखता है क्या-क्या नॉलेज
रखता है कब कौन-कौन सी रिपोजिटरी को मैनेज
करता है इसके रिपोजिटरी में क्या-क्या पुश
कर रहा है कमिट्स कर रहा है ये सारी चीजें
आप देख सकते हैं अब मेरे पास ये यूजर है
मान लो मुझे इसको फॉलो करना है तो मैं
यहां पे भी कर लूंगा लेकिन मुझे क्या है
मैं एक बार ट्राई करूंगा
लाइक काइंड
ऑफ कोई लाइक है कुछ ऐसे ठीक है तो ज्यादा
कुछ यहां पे नहीं मिल रहा मैं यहां पे इस
वाले ब्राउजर में आ जाता हूं यहां लिकन
लॉगइन है तो फुल प्रोफाइल आपको दिख
जाएगी टाइम एट लाइक ठीक है नॉट मच ऑफ द
इंफो कुछ ज्यादा इंफो आपको मिल नहीं रही
यहां पे तो चलेगा कोई कोई टेंशन नहीं है
आपको यहां पे कुछ मिला है चलो अब हम कुछ
और कीवर्ड्स को यहां पे लेके आ जाते हैं
लाइक वी कैन सी चलिए डेटाबेस से रिलेटेड
आपने बोला तो यहां पर डीवी पासवर्ड है
डीवी डेटाबेस है डेटाबेस पासवर्ड डेटाबेस
स्कीमा ठीक है मैं सिंपल ना एक डेटाबेस से
रिलेटेड ही बस सर्च कर लेता हूं ओनली
डेटाबेस सर्च कर लेता हूं ठीक है ओनली
डेटाबेस क्योंकि बहुत सारे कीवर्ड जो है
वो ऑलरेडी फिल्टर्ड होंगे आपके तो यहां पे
मैं यहां पे सिंपली डटा बेस सर्च कर लेता
हूं एंड नॉट एग्जांपल एंड नॉट टेस्ट कोई
टेस्ट नहीं होना चाहिए एग्जांपल नहीं होना
चाहिए ठीक है लेट्स सी व्हाट वी आर गेटिंग
पांच कोड्स ओनली मिले हैं एंड यहां पे
आपको कुछ चीजें मिली
है दिस वन दिस
इमेज ओके क्या इमेज है
ये
ओके स्क्रीनशॉट यह कैसा स्क्रीनशॉट है
आपको इमेज के अंदर भी सिक्योरिटी
क्रेडेंशियल मिल सकती है याद रखिएगा इमेज
के अंदर भी बहुत सारी चीजें मिल जाती है
तो यहां पे अभी तो ये इनका इमेज
है एंड व्हाट वी गट हियर क्या है यह देखा
जाए
जरा ओके नो एसक्यूएल रियल टाइम होस्टिंग
ऑफ डेटाबेस दिस प्रोजेक्ट यूटिलाइज द
फावेक्स ऑथेंटिकेशन ठीक है
ओके नॉट नॉट सिंपली अ
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन ओके ओके नथिंग
मच कुछ खास नहीं है यहां पे एंड यहां पे
कुछ मिला हमें फवे डेटाबेस जए ठीक है
फ्रॉम जी स्टिक नथिंग मच सिक्योरिटी टल की
r.net s बॉक्स चेक आउट ठीक है ये एक सब
डोमेन है यहां पे यह सब डोमेन आपको एक सब
डोमेन मिल चुका है आपके फदर टेस्टिंग के
लिए कर सकते यूज आप इसको सब डोमेन
न्यूमरेशन के लिए बेसिकली सब डोमेन के
अंदर कुछ सेंसिटिव फाइल्स निकाल डायरेक्ट
ब्रूट फोर्सिंग करनी हो तो आप इस पर कर
सकते हैं यर वी गट यहां पर डेटा बेस टाइप
डेटाबेस ठीक है यहां पर रापिड नेट कंटेंट
अगेन पेमेंट मेथड इमेज हैय हा
ओके ओके ओके ओके व्हाट इज दिस व्हाट इज
दिस व्ट इज दिस जस्ट वेट गाइस यहां पर
हमें कुछ एक्सेस की मिला यह बंदा ने
मास्टर डेव 2018 यह कब का पुल कब का यह
कमिटमेंट है यह ड एनवी हमें फाइल एक मिली
है
एंड इज इ रिलेटेड टू रैपिड सम हाउ कुछ है
नहीं यार एआई डिटेक्शन नॉर्मल नॉर्मल ठीक
है रिपोजिटरी रिपोजिटरी काफी सारे
रिपोजिटरी है यहां पे बट यहां पे
sandbox-virtual
ये अ लेट्स चेक लेट्स चेक गाइज अ दैट माइट
बी समथिंग ड एनवी
फाइल लेट्स सी टेस्ट नहीं होना चाहिए
बिकॉज़ क्योंकि हमने टेस्ट को ऑलरेडी हटा
दिया था अ यह देखो यहां पे कुछ हो सकता है
लेट्स सी व्हाट इज दिस यह बेस 64 का
इनकोडिंग ओ हो हो हो बेस 64 ओ माय गॉड
क्रैक क्रैक स्टेशन पे चलते हैं एंड
पासवर्ड क्रैक अ सॉरी इंक्रिप्शन क्रैक
करने की कोशिश करते हैं वी गॉट अ
इंक्रिप्शन यहां पे इंक्रिप्टेड वे में
रखा हुआ है यहां पे मैं एक काम करता हूं
जस्ट वेट
गाइस वेयर इट इज वर इट इज कहां गया
भैया यहां पे हमें मिल रहा था ना यह वाली
तो ये बेस 64 इनकोडिंग है तो देख लेते हैं
क्या है एक्सेस
की प की है ये सो लेट्स पुट इट हियर एंड
लेट्स क्रैक अरे भाई फायर हाइड्रेंट यह
रहा यह रहा यह रहा
वेरीफाई क्रैक हैशेज लेट्स सी
अनरिकॉग्नाइज्ड ओके बैड फॉर्मेट
बैड फॉर्मेट है मे बी दिस कैन बी इनकोडेड
दिस कैन बी इनकोडेड मे बी डबल इनकोडेड और
समथिंग ट सो डू वन
थिंग क्रक
बस सॉरी बेस
64 लेट्स ट्राई
हियर लेट्स ट्राई हियर इफ वी कैन सी यर
हियर वी गेट दिस वन दिस इज नॉट नॉट अ
प्रॉपर प्लेन टेक्स्ट यहां पर आते हैं ब
64 डिकोड लेट्स सी इफ यू आर गेटिंग
समथिंग ओ द कैरेक्टर इनकोडिंग वा ड आओ बट
हाई प्र दैट दिस इज रंग बिकॉज यू कैन गेट
रंग रिजल्ट्स ठीक है कुछ रंग रिजल्ट्स
हमें मिले
हैं ओके वी गट सम रंग रिजल्ट्स हियर बट
कोई बात नहीं यहां पे मैं कुछ और देखता
हूं लोकल होस्ट ठीक है डी बग ओके स्टोर
लांसर ऐप नेम इज स्टोर लांसर ठीक
है कोई बात
नहीं स्टोर
लांसर ओके यहां पे है मेन हमारा यह तो
स्टोर लैंसर कोई है दिस इज स्टोर
लांसर बेस 64 में दिस इज
अ नो नो दिस इज बेस 64 ये देखो ना बेस 64
यहां पे दिया हुआ है दिस इज बेस 64 ठीक है
तो मैं एक काम करता हूं अ
यह रही s बॉक्स वाली यह रही rapido.com
या दिस इ डिफरेंट दिस नॉट रैपिड या
कनेक्टेड नहीं है ठीक है यह अलग है रैपिड
का बिल्कुल डिफरेंट है यहां पर जो कि
बिल्कुल यहां पर डायरेक्टली यहां पर
विजिबल है यहां प आप डायरेक्टली ऑनलाइन कर
लो ना क्या जरूरत है यार ऑनलाइन कर लो ना
डिकोड बप शूट में जाने की क्या जरूरत है
ऑनलाइन बहुत सारे अवेलेबल है बट ये हमारे
स्टोर लांसर का था हमारे काम का नहीं है
ये स्टोर लांसर डिफरेंट हमें चाहिए रैपिड
वाला तो हमें यहां पर एक चीज मिली है
एंड यस वी कैन रिपोर्ट इट आई वी कैन
रिपोर्ट इट क्या लगता है आपको रिपोर्ट हम
कर सकते हैं देखो कुछ भी मिले रिपोर्ट कर
देना चाहिए बाकी आपको सामने से कुछ अगर
इंपैक्ट पूछेंगे तो बाद में हम इंपैक्ट का
दिखा देंगे देखेंगे कि क्या करना है कि
रैपिड एक्सेस की को यूज कैसे कर सकते हैं
चलो यहां पे
रैपिड एक्सेस की
यूसेज यहां पर दे रखा
है कुछ ना कुछ तो करके रहेंगे भाई यह
[संगीत]
रही यह
रहा रैपिड प्र ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है रैपिड
यूज एपीआई की रिक्वेस्ट ठीक है ओके सो व्ट
वी आर गोइंग टू डू हम एक बार इसको रिपोर्ट
करेंगे एक बार इसको जस्ट ल रिपोर्ट इट
बिकॉज लेट्स सी य आउट ऑफ स्कोप में ना हो
स बॉक्स इ ओट
मैन s बने इ आउट ऑ स्कोप और आउट ऑफ स्कोप
पॉलिसी एसेट्स आर वन होस्टेड बाय थर्ड
पार्टी सच एज डिस्क्राइब टारगेट्स बट नॉट
लिमिटेड टू ऑटोमेशन य स्क्रिप्ट फ्रॉम एनी
काइंड अगेन सपोर्टेड फॉर्म कंपलीटली आउट
ऑफ स्कोप यानी sandbox-virtual
इंक्लूड वी कैन इंक्लूड राइट चलिए इसको
इंक्लूड देखो हम रिपोर्ट कर देते हैं नो
मैटर लाइक व्हाट वी गेट मुझे क्या
रिस्पांस आएगा उससे कोई दिक्कत नहीं है बट
या वी कैन रिपोर्ट इट तो चलो रिपोर्ट भी
कर ही देते हैं राइट लेट्स रिपोर्ट चलो
हैकर लॉगिन पर चलते
हैं यहां पर
मैं
पासवर्ड पासवर्ड अब मुझे याद नहीं है कि
यह पासवर्ड सही है या नहीं
है इज इट
करेक्ट यस इट्स करेक्ट सो
लेट्स सबमिट रिपोर्ट पर क्लिक कर देते हैं
ठीक है सबमिट रिपोर्ट पर चले जाते
हैं एंड यहां पर आपको
देखो
सबमिट टाइटल यहां देना है ठीक है हेल्प अस
टू गेट एन आईडिया ऑफ व्हाट दिस वनरे
बिलिटी इज अबाउट तो यहां पर हम कर सकते
हैं सेंसिटिव एपीआई की लीकेज ऐसे कर सकते
हैं यह चीज ठीक है
[संगीत]
अ सेंसिटिव एपीआई की लीकेज ये हमने डाल
दिया टारगेट अब टारगेट कौन सा है भैया तो
टारगेट हम देख लेते हैं एड
ठीक है रड डट हमारे टारगेट है यहां पे
वलने बिलिटी टाइप आपको सेलेक्ट कर लेना है
तो सेंसिटिव डाटा सेंसिटिव एक्सपोजर है
यहां पे तो देख सकते हैं यह वाला
अ यहां से देख लेते हैं सेंसिटिव
डिस्क्लोजर ऑफ सीक्रेट्स फॉर पब्लिकली
एक्सेसिबल एसेट्स डिस्क्लोजर ऑफ सीक्रेट
पीट लीकेज एक्सपोजर डिस्क्लोजर फॉर इंटरनल
एसेट्स यहां पे गिट हब से रिलेटेड कुछ है
क्या यहां पे गिट हब का सर्च कर लेते हैं
अगर कुछ है तो गिट हब का कुछ नहीं है तो
तो सेंसिटिव के अंदर में हम कर लेते हैं
ठीक है जो होगा देखा जाएगा सही बात है
बिल्कुल सही बोल रहा है पब्लिकली
एक्सेसिबल एसेट्स के अंदर जा जाते हैं और
इसको कर लेते हैं ये पीव कैटेगरी में आ
रहा है फिलहाल के लिए पब्लिकली एक्सेसिबल
एसेट्स है हमारा ये पब्लिकली एक्सेसिबल है
[संगीत]
दैट्ची आउट हियर रिपोजिटरी में गाइडलाइंस
यहां पे क्या है डिस्क्राइब द लेबिलिटी
एंड इट्स इंपैक्ट एंड ऑल ये सब चीजें आपको
थोड़ी सी आपको यहां पे देनी है गाइडलाइंस
बतानी होती है बस और कुछ भी नहीं लेबिलिटी
के बारे में तो मैं यहां पे क्या कर देता
हूं सिंपल मैं इस इस सब सारी चीजों को एक
बंद हटा देता हूं
एंड यहां पे अगर आप देखेंगे तो देखो यहां
पे अगर आप देखोगे तो यहां पे आपको पता चल
जाएगा कि क्या-क्या लिखा यहां पे कैसे
आपको लिखना होता है ये आपको पता चल जाएगा
ठीक है ओवरव्यू ऑफ द लेबिलिटी ठीक है
ओवरव्यू आपको दे देना है बिजनेस इंपैक्ट
स्टेप्स टू रीप्रोड्यूस एंड स्क्रीनशॉट
अगर देना है तो आप दे सकते हैं ड्राइव
वगैरह में डाल के दे सकते हैं ठीक है ना
या फिर यहां पर भी अटैचमेंट डाल सकते हैं
प्रूफ ऑफ कंसेप्ट अगर आपको कुछ चाहिए अगर
कुछ देना है तो दे सकते हैं ठीक है बट
फिलहाल यहां पे क्या कर सकते हैं सिंपल तो
वल्नरेबल
टाइप में वनबिल यहां पर कर सकते
हैं एपिया एप कीज प कीज प की ली केस इस
तरीके से ठीक
है यस यस मैं आपको दिखा दे रहा हूं आप लोग
इसको देखते
जा कौन सी चीज थी यहां पर दैट इज द सैंड
बॉक्स यह
वाला साब एडनेट ठीक है यह वाली थी रैपिड
एक्सेस की एंड रैपिड सीक्रेट की ठीक है
दोनों चीज लिकेज है तो दोनों चीज करते
प सेंसिटिव
कीज लीकेज ठीक है हमने कर दिया एंड यहां
पर
लीकेज यहां पर अब लिख दिया अब इसके
डिटेल्स में आ जाते हैं डिटेल्स में कुछ
आप डाल सकते
हैं
द रैपिड पप रैपिड पप ही है ना कौन सा है
रैपिड एक्सेस की एंड रैपिड सीक्रेट की ठीक
है तो दोनों
चीजें रैपिड एक्सेस की
एंड सीक्रेट की इज लीक्ड
इन इन
अ गट हब
रिपोजिटरी इन इन अ पब्लिक गिट हब
रिपोजिटरी लोकेटेड एट लोकेटेड ट अब यहां
पर आपको इसकी लोकेशन दे देनी है जो इस
रिपोजिटरी का जो य लोकेशन है बेसिकली सो
लेट्स टेक आउट द लोकेशन यर यह वाली लोकेशन
है तो यह लोकेशन मैं यहां पर मेंशन कर
देता हूं ठीक है यहां पर यह लोकेशन मेंशन
कर देता हूं ठीक है चलिए यह तो आपको मेंशन
हो गया अब यहां पर आपको बताना है इसका
इंपैक्ट क्या है इंपैक्ट ऑफ
दिस वल्नरेबल
एनी
अटैकर अटैकर हु गट हु गट एक्सेस टू दिस की
कैन कैन परफॉर्म द परफॉर्म द
[संगीत]
आर्बिट्रेरी
एक्शन ऑन बिहाव
ऑफ
द ऑथेंटिकेटेड
यूजर विद सेम
प्रिविलेज वि सेम
प्रिविलेज प्रिविलेज की स्पेलिंग देख लेना
यार हा
प्रिविलेज ऑफ दैट यूजर ठीक है यहां पर
क्या गॉट एक्सेस टू दिस कीज कैन परफॉर्म द
आर्बिट्री आर्बिट्रेरी एक्शन आर्बिट्रेरी
या ऐसे बोल सकते हैं और मेलिश
एक्शन ऑन बिहा ऑफ द ऑथेंटिकेटेड यूजर विद
द सेम प्रिविलेजेस विद द सेम प्रिविलेजेस
विद द सेम प्रिविलेजेस ठीक है ये हमने ये
कर लिया हां रैपिड ठीक है यहां
पे रैपिड सेंसिटिव की लीकेज राइट तो यहां
पे रैपिड एक्सेस की एंड सीक्रेट की इज लीड
इन पब्लिक गट रिपोजिटरी ऐसे एंड इंपैक्ट
ऑफ दिली कोई भी जो है वो आर्बिट्री और मशस
एक्शन बफ ऑफ द थट के यूजर्स विथ द सेम
प्रिविलेजेस ठीक है ये हम कर लिया स्टेप्स
टू रीप्रोड्यूस स्टेप्स टू
रीप्रोड्यूस लेट्स सी जो भी होगा देखो
रिजल्ट मैं आपको क्यों यह रिपोर्ट कर रहा
हूं मैं आपको बता रहा हूं रिजल्ट हमें
नहीं पता हमें नहीं जानना रिजल्ट के बारे
में रिपोर्ट करो बस ट्स इट स्टेप्स ू रिप
रीप्रोड्यूस गो
टू गो टू ये
वाला दिस वन गो टू यह वाला
सेकंड एट
द बॉटम बॉटम ऑफ दिस
रैपर ऑफ दिस फाइल ऑफ दिस फाइल ठीक है एट द
बॉटम ऑफ दिस फाइल यू कैन सी द कीज ठीक
है
प्लीज
प्लीज सी द अटैच स्क्रीनशॉट्स
आल्सो स्क्रीनशॉट आल्सो ठीक
है ओके ट्स इट यहां पे बस सिंपल इंपैक्ट
यहां पर क्या हो गया कोई भी अटैकर है अब
जैसे इसका इंपैक्ट देखो अगर तुम्हें थोड़ा
डिटेल में जाना है मान लो डिटेल में और भी
लिखना है तो डिटेल में लिख सकते हो कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है अब जैसे कि कैसे मान लो
यहां पे चलो पहले एक बार रिपोर्ट कर देते
हैं पहले उसके बाद देखते हैं ठीक है प्लीज
सी द अटच स्क्रीन स्क्रीन आल्सो ठीक है अब
यहां पे अटैच करना है स्क्रीनशॉट यहां पे
तो मैं क्या करूंगा यहां पे जाऊंगा एंड
यहां पे मैं स्निपिंग टूल यूज कर लेता हूं
एंड हियर आई वड डायरेक्टली स्क्रीनशॉट दिस
वन ठीक है स्क्रीनशॉट ले लिया हमने यहां
पे इसको हम सेव कर देते हैं कंट्रोल एस कर
देते हैं एंड स्क्रीनशॉट डेस्कटॉप प डाल
देते
हैं एंड यहां से हम कर देते हैं
रैपिड रैपिड डेस्कटॉप प हमने डाल दिया
दैट्ची कर देते हैं अ अ रैपिड कहां गया
भैया रैपिड ये वाली एंड दैट्ची है ये हमने
कर
दिया ओके इंपैक्ट आप अपने अकॉर्डिंग लिख
सकते हैं कुछ भी कोई कोई भी दिक्कत नहीं
है इंपैक्ट आप अपने अकॉर्डिंग कुछ भी लिख
सकते हैं आप आपको जो मर्जी आप लिखिए थोड़ा
सा डिटेल लिखिए तो ज्यादा बढ़िया रहेगा
एकदम एकदम सही बात है ज्यादा जितना डिटेल
लिखेगा उतना बढ़िया रहेगा ठीक है तो यहां
पे मैंने अभी लिख दिया क्योंकि ये
डायरेक्टली सेंसिटिव डेटा एक्सपोजर
एक्सपोजर है तो आप नॉर्मली भी बोल देंगे
कि हां ऐसा है अगर वो इंपैक्टफुल है मतलब
उनके लिए यूजफुल है है वो चीज नहीं होनी
चाहिए तो वो एक्सेप्ट कर लेंगे आपका ठीक
है कोलैबोरेटर यहां कोई दोस्त है जिसके
साथ हंट कर रहे हैं तो कोलैबोरेटर ऐड कर
सकते हैं यहां पे आप कर दीजिए ये चीज एंड
दैट्ची पे क्लिक कीजिएगा रिपोर्ट हो जाएगा
बस आपको यहां पे जाके इनको दिखा देना है
स्क्रीनशॉट दे दी बस
दैट्ची है अ
हियर यस रिपोर्ट जा चुका है बेसिकली आप
इसको ट्रैक कर सकते हैं यहां पे अ
प्रोफाइल के अंदर में जाके आप प्रोफाइल के
अंदर में बेसिकली जाके यहां पे
अ ये ये कुछ यहां पे बेसिकली पॉइंट्स
पॉइंट्स जो भी है वो बताता है यहां पे एक
बार एक बार पॉइंट्स जो भी आपके जो आपको
मिलेंगे वो पॉइंट्स वगैरह दिखाएगा क्राउड
स्ट्रीम में बाकी सारे क्राउड्स जो हैं अ
जो भी आपके जो डाटा वगैरह आते हैं वो सारी
चीजें जो है आपकी यहां पे आएंगी ठीक है तो
हमने रिपोर्ट कर दिया यहां पे एंड यहां पे
ये कुछ चीजें हैं यहां पे बेसिकली लिए
स्टैट्स वगैरह आपको दिखाते हैं बेसिकली
बिकॉज यहां पे अब क्या है कि अ ये एक मेरा
जेनरिक एक जेनरिक प्रोफाइल है तो यहां पे
आपको ज्यादा कुछ दिखेगा नहीं यहां पे ठीक
है तो हमने यहां पे रिपोर्ट कर दिया है
नाउ वी विल सी अचीवमेंट में आपको
अचीवमेंट्स वगैरह जो जो भी होंगे यहां पे
मिल जाएंगे जैसे ये कुछ अचीवमेंट p1 वरियर
लेवल सबमिशन शोगन बाउंट लेवल वन ये सारे
जो अचीवमेंट्स है वो सारी चीजें आपको यहां
पे मिल जाएंगे ठीक है तो
दैट्ची इस तरीके से जिसमें रिसर्चस के नाम
वगैरह जो होते हैं वो सारी चीजें होती है
ठीक है यहां पर डिस्कवरी प आप आएंगे तो
यहां पे बेसिकली प्रोग्राम जो है वो सारी
आपको आ जाएगी ठीक है तो अब यहां पे
रिपोर्ट कर दिया हमने एंड मेरे ख्याल से
मुझे कोई मेल भी आया होगा
शायद लेट मी सी इफ आई गट अ मेल अभी तो
नहीं आया बट
आएगा ठीक है यू विल गेट द मेल
राइट चलिए तो वी गट वी रिपोर्टेड वन एंड
यहां पे यहां प इनवाइट में आप जाएंगे ना
तो मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं इन्वाइट्स जैसे
कोई अगर अ आपको कोई प्राइवेट प्रोग्राम के
इन्वाइट्स आएंगे तो यहीं पे आपको
इन्वाइट्स मिल जाएंगे जैसे मेरे पास क्या
था एक्सेप्टेड इनवाइट मेरे पास दो
प्राइवेट प्रोग्राम के इन्वाइट्स आए थे
मैं जैसे कि आपको बोला मैंने कि मैं बहुत
ज्यादा एक्टिव नहीं था बग बाउंटीज में
बहुत ही कम टाइम देता था क्योंकि मेरे पास
टाइम होता नहीं था ठीक है तो अभी मैं
थोड़ा सा देने लगा हूं टाइम क्योंकि
बेसिकली आपको सिखाना भी है तो टाइम देने
लगा हूं तो ये पहले मेरे पास दो प्राइवेट
प्रोग्राम्स के जब मैंने पीव हंट किया था
तो उस टाइम में मुझे ये बेटर हेल्प और
कन्वर्ट किट इसका मुझे आया हुआ था दैट इट
यहां पे पेमेंट्स प जाएंगे तो बेसिकली
आपको पेमेंट्स से रिलेटेड जो चीजें होंगी
लाइक कोई अगर पेमेंट ओ मेंट हुआ है अगर
अभी तो ये थोड़ी देर मतलब कुछ ही दिन का
यह दिखाता है मतलब कुछ दिन का ही पेमेंट
का हिस्ट्री दिखाता है पूरा आपको नहीं
दिखाएगा ये ठीक है एंड यहां पे यह
प्रोफाइल है राइट
सो ओके तो प्रोग्राम्स प चलते हैं अगेन
अगेन वी आर गोइंग टू द प्रोग्राम एंड जो
प्रोग्राम है पहले उस पर चल देते
हैं देखते हैं क्या होता है
अ देखते हैं क्या होता
है यहां पे ये प्रोग्राम में हम आ चुके
हैं यहां योर सबमिशंस जो है इस पे आप
सिंपली आ जाइएगा जब योर सबमिशन पे तो यहां
पे आपको ये सबमिशन जो है वो दिखाएगा यहां
पे एंड ये दिखाएगा सेंसिटिव एपीआई की
लीकेज एंड यहां पे आपने p1 एंड न्यू है ये
अभी तक कोई रिप्लाई उधर से नहीं आया
बेसिकली ये कितने देर में करते हैं
रेस्पों आपको मैं दिखा देता हूं इसी
प्रोग्राम के यहां पे दिखा होगा वैलिडेशन
विद इन फाइव डेज तो फाइव डेज के अंदर में
आपको यहां पे बेसिकली कुछ ना कुछ अपडेट
मिल जाएगा कि मानते एक्सेप्ट करते हैं
नहीं करते हैं नहीं करेंगे तो नॉट
एप्लीकेबल लगा देंगे या डुप्लीकेट्स भी
लगा सकते हैं कुछ भी लगा सकते हैं व्हाट
एवर तो यहां पे आपको यहां पे दे दिया अब
यहां पे उनके तरफ से कुछ आएगा ए ये जो
आपकी इमेज है जो आपने डाली हुई थी बेसिकली
जो अपलोड करी थी ये इमेज ये वाली डाली थी
ना भाई कौन सी डाली थी ये वाली सीक्रेट की
एंड एक्सेस की ये वाली मिल रही है ठीक है
तो
दैट्ची इंपैक्ट ऑफ दिस वलने एबिलिटी एनी
अटैकर हु गॉट एक्सेस टू दिस कीज कैन
परफॉर्म द आर्बिट ऑ मलेशियन बि हाल्फ ऑफ़
द ऑथेंटिकेट यूजर विद सेम प्रिविलेज ठीक
है तो अब ये रिपोर्ट का जो इंपैक्ट है ना
जितना अच्छे से आप लिखेंगे उतना ज्यादा
बेटर होगा ये तो मैंने आपको दिखाने के लिए
लिख दिया और सबसे बड़ी बात इसलिए क्योंकि
यहां पे गाइस ये जो है सेंसिटिव कीज
एक्सपोजर जब आप सेंसिटिव एक्सपोजर डेटा
एक्सपोजर आप रिपोर्ट करते हैं ना तो आपको
जो कीज वगैरह एपीआई वगैरह मिलती है वो
जनरली आपको एक्सेप्ट कर दी जाती है अगर वो
वैलिड है तो इंपैक्टफुल है तभी या ऑफ
स्कोप नहीं होना चाहिए आइटम तो मुझे थोड़ा
सा इस पर डाउट है क्योंकि यह जो स्कोप है
वह आपको दिख रहा होगा कि स बक्स api.net
है और इन्होंने अपने प्रोग्राम में मेंशन
करा है कि आउट ऑफ स्कोप आइटम्स है ये वाली
s बॉक्स बट s बक्स एपीआई नहीं है कुछ यहां
पे बट थर्ड पार्टी सर्विसेस लिखा इन्होंने
तो शायद ये आउट ऑफ स्कोप चला जाए मे बी
मतलब जैसा कि मुझे लग रहा है ठीक
है अ ओके ओके ठीक है ओके आज तो मजा आ गया
रिप्लाई बिल्कुल बिल्कुल जो रिप्लाई आएगा
मैं बता दूंगा बट मुझे थोड़ा सा डाउट है
यहां पे ठीक है चलिए तो ये तो हमें मिल
गया एक चीज मिली हमें तो हमने यहां पे
रिपोर्ट कर दी चलिए अब नाउ वी गट इट हियर
अब हमें इसको क्लोज कर देना है
एंड नथिंग हियर इसमें भी कुछ खास यहां पे
था नहीं टेस्ट वाली थी तो ये हमने क्या
किया सर्च किया था भैया हमने सर्च किया था
डीबी डेटाबेस ठीक है और कुछ तो सर्च किया
नहीं था लेट्स लेट्स वेट हां तो ये
यहां पर मिल गया और एक और चीज यहां पर
मिली हमें क्या मिली है यह देखते हैं नेट
यहां कुछ मिला है क्या नेट
चलिए नर्मल सा डॉक था डेटाबेस वाला मैं
दिखा देता हूं कौन सा डॉक था यह वाला डॉक
था देख लो य सर्च वाली सर्च आ रही होगी
सचय नहीं नहीं यह सच यह नहीं था या यह
वाला डॉक था मैं आपको दिखाता हूं जस्ट
वेट ये वाला नेट उसके बाद डेटाबेस हमें
फाइंड करना था डेटाबेस से कीवर्ड रिलेटेड
कुछ भी मिल चलेगा नॉट टेस्ट नॉट एग्जांपल
यानी टेस्ट वाले डेटाबेस नहीं चाहिए
एग्जांपल वाले नहीं चाहिए क्योंकि वो
बेकार के होते हैं वो आप रिपोर्ट करेंगे
नॉट एप्लीकेबल हो जाता है क्योंकि वो
टेस्ट एनवायरमेंट के होते हैं एग्जांपल के
लिए होते हैं नॉट अ रियल वन तो हमने वो
एक्स लाइक फिल्टर आउट कर दिया था ठीक
है हरीश दास यू आर ग्रेट थैंक यू
हरीश शैलेश एक क्वेश्चन था हां शैलेश
पूछो सर आपका सेशन बेस्ट है पूरा डिटेल
में बताता हूं थैंक यू थैंक यू थैंक यू तो
अभी फिलहाल हमने रिपोर्ट किया एंड इसका
रिजल्ट जो भी आएगा जो रिपोर्ट अभी
सेंसिटिव डाटा का किया हमने अ वो रिजल्ट
आपसे शेयर मैं जरूर कर दूंगा टेंशन आपको
नहीं लेनी है अ बट मुझे थोड़ा डाउट है
वैलिड का लेकिन फिर भी जस्ट लेट्स सी
दैट्ची
है ओके चलिए अब यहां पे हमने एक डेटाबेस
का किया यहां पे अब यहां पे हम और भी
कीवर्ड्स को इस्तेमाल कर सकते हैं ऐसे आप
करके कीवर्ड्स बहुत सारे यूज कर सकते कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है आपको जो भी यूज करना है आप
यूज कीजिए कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है ठीक है अब
मुझे सिर्फ और सिर्फ लेट्स
सपोज मुझे सिर्फ और कोई कीवर्ड नहीं डालनी
मुझे सिर्फ रप नेट यह सर्च करना है मान लो
मैं ऐसे भी कर सकता हूं मैं सिर्फ रप नेट
सर्च करूंगा अभी फिलहाल के
लिए
सॉरी यह
देखो मैंने सिर्फ नेट सर्च किया एंड यहां
प कुछ चीजें यहां पर मुझे मिली जैसे र नेट
की यहां पे कोड कुछ यहां पे कुछ मिला ठीक
है बढ़िया यहां से कुछ id.in के कुछ चीजें
मिली ओनली मैंने कोई अभी की सिर्फ और
सिर्फ यहां पे आपको दिख रहा होगा कीवर्ड
ऐड किया है डॉर्क यूज नहीं किया है यहां
पे कोड में 462 कोड्स मिले हैं यहां पे
रिपोजिटरी थ्री मिली है इश्यूज टू मिले
हैं पोल रिक्वेस्ट अब रिपोजिटरी में देखते
हैं भाई तीन कौन से हैं भैया तो एक ये है
एक ये है और एक ये है ठीक है तीन
रिपोजिटरीज है यहां पे थर्ड पार्टी
है ये वाली रिपोजिटरी देख लेते हैं एक बार
दिस वन रैपिड ए ट ना ठीक
है एंड ये यूजर को देख लेते हैं इज ही
एसोसिएटेड विथ
रैपिड
गलेब गलेनो ठीक है अभी तो बहुत कुछ बचा है
आज के सेशन में थोड़ा वेट कीजिए इनको हम
लिंकन पर फाइंड करने की कोशिश कर लेते
हैं
गले देखते हैं यह है कि नहीं एसोसिएटेड
उससे
लिंगन ग्लेव से यही है क्या अच्छा ये कुछ
ज्यादा ही बड़े पोस्ट हैं इनके क्या है यह
फिनटेक अ ओके स बिजनेस स्कूल फैट पाइथन
कोडर ठीक है कोडर तो है अच्छी बात है बट
रैपिड से
रिलेटेड शायद नहीं है साइफ पे है स्लीक पे
थे कुबिया पे आईसी रस बैंक डालोड ठीक है
नॉट रिलेटेड टू रैपिड सो थर्ड पार्टी हो
गया यह भी तो कुछ खास आपको यहां पे मिलेगा
नहीं ठीक है इश्यूज में भी आप आ सकते हैं
इश्यूज में क्या हो जाते हैं गाइस कभी-कभी
इश्यूज के अंदर कुछ कुछ चीज आपको मिल सकती
है कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें आप देख सकते हैं
पुल रिक्वेस्ट में कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें
मिल सकती है वो भी आप देख सकते हैं ठीक है
तो वो आपके ऊपर है टोटली आपके ऊपर डिपेंड
करता है चलिए तो हम यहां पे r.net से हमने
सर्च कर लिया हमें कुछ ज्यादा कुछ खास
हमें इसका पर्टिकुलर रिपोजिटरी नहीं मिला
आप डबल कोट अगर हटाते हैं इस तरीके से तो
आप इस तरीके से भी सर्च कर सकते हैं आपको
ऑलमोस्ट सिमिलर रिजल्ट जो है मिल जाता है
अब यहां पे ये तो था
rapid.com से भी रिलेटेड कुछ चाहिए तो
मैंने dp.com यहां
पे एंटर किया लेट्स सी इफ वी हैव सम
रिपोजिटरीज रिलेटेड टू rapid.com कुछ इनका
नेटिव रिपोजिटरी है क्या कुछ खास है मुझे
यहां पर दिख नहीं रहा टेस्ट है गी रैपिड
पेमेंट चेक
आउट मच नॉट मच ऑफ ये समझ आप लोगों को मजा
आ रहा है
ना
चलो कीवर्ड शेयर हो जाएगी हमारे कीवर्ड
शेयर हो जाएगी आपको टेंशन मत लो आपको
कीवर्ड शेयर कर दूंगा मैं जो शेयरिंग जो
भी अभी मिल रहे है ना आपको कीवर्ड वो मैं
शेयर कर दूंगा उसके लिए टेंशन नहीं लेना
है आपको करना क्या है मैं आपको बता सिंपल
सा दिखा देता
हूं हां जी आपको करना क्या है आपको सिंपली
जाना है अ हमारे डेनिक्स अकेडमी पप ए पप
पे प् स्टोर से इंस्टॉल कर लीजिएगा
डेनिक्स अकेडमी नाम से आ जाएगा ठीक है
इसको ओपन कर लीजिएगा एंड यहां पे ये वाला
जो फ्री कोर्स है इसको आप जवाइन कर
लीजिएगा ₹10 का है वो फ्री ही है ऑलमोस्ट
इसके कंटेंट में आप जब जाएंगे ना कंटेंट
में तो यहां पे आपको बग बाउंट रिसोर्सेस
मिलेंगे ठीक है आप इसमें ही यह मैं फाइल्स
अपलोड कर दूंगा अभी पहले ओ चेकलिस्ट है
सडन चीटशीट है टीम चीटशीट है
googleupdate.exe को जरूर इंस्टॉल कर
लीजिएगा ठीक है ये इस तरीके से आपको
दिखेगा ये ठीक है दैट इट चलिए बैक टू
हंटिंग अ वापस से हंटिंग पे आ जाते हैं एक
बार चलिए ये तो हमने हो गया ये हमने कर
लिया सिंपल सा चीज है अब हम इसमें और भी
चीजें ऐड ऑन करेंगे और भी चीजें कीवर्ड्स
को यूज करने वाले हैं ये तो बहुत सिंपल सा
कीवर्ड हमने यूज किया देखो कुछ
इंटरेस्टिंग कीवर्ड सर्च कर लेते हैं जैसे
कि एक्सेस टोकन एडमिन यूजर एडमिन हां
एडमिन से रिलेटेड कुछ सर्च कर लेते हैं
जस्ट ओनली एडमिन क्योंकि एडमिन ओनली सर्च
करेंगे तो बाकी बहुत सारी चीजें मिल
जाएंगी ठीक है तो rapid.com
एंड यहां पर कर देते हैं एडमिन एंड यहां
पर ओबवियसली नॉट टैग लगाएंगे नॉट टेस्ट
नॉट एग्जांपल एग्जांपल एंड टेस्ट हम नहीं
करने वाले हैं ओबवियसली हमें कुछ मिलता है
क्या पांच कोड मिले हैं पांच है रिजल्ट्स
में कोड वाले में कुछ देखते हैं एडमिन कुछ
है कि नहीं एडमिन इनसाइड अ कंट्रोलर कॉल्ड
एडमिन
ओके नथिंग मच यहां क्या है कोड इग्निटर
ठीक है रैपिड रैपिड पीएचपी माय एडमिन दिस
इज पीएचपी माय एडमिन नॉट इंटरेस्टिंग
रैपिड रैपिड रप रैपिड कॉल्ड एडमिन नॉट
इंटरेस्टिंग रड एडमिन कोडन सटर नहीं है
कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग साइट एडमिन क्या है ये
r.com
नॉर्मल नॉर्मल नॉर्मल मच कुछ ज्यादा कुछ
खास मिला नहीं कंट्रोल एफ एडमिन लेट्स सी
कुछ है क्या कंट्रोलर एडमिन एडमिन
क्रोड एडमिन कड
ओके पीके वैल्यू शो ठीक
है
[संगीत]
अच्छा य डेटा एडिट बटन इ मेथड कॉल्ड क्रूड
इनसाइड कंट्रोलर कॉल्ड एडमिन वी कैन ठीक
है एडमिन क्रूड ठीक
है कुछ ज्यादा कुछ खास तो हमें यहां पर
नहीं मिल रहा देखने को वैसे तो बट लेट्स
सी लेट्स सी लेट्स सी लेट्स सी लेट्स
सी च इट इज रिलेटेड टू कुछ भी नहीं है
यहां पे नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट एडमिन एडमिन
एडमिन नथिंग
नथिंग ओ कुछ खास नहीं है यहां पे रिजल्ट्स
में ट्स वी कैन स्किप दैट ठीक है हम इसको
स्किप कर सकते हैं कोई भी प्रॉब्लम नहीं
है यहां पे आपको अगेन कोई गेट अप
रिपोजिटरी ऐसे मिल जाती है जो इस रिलेटेड
कुछ काम करती है तो आपको सर्च करना है कोई
यूजर मिल जाता है जो रैपिड के लिए काम
करता है उसको फॉलो करके एंड उसको क फॉलो
कर सकते हैं राइट ठीक है ये काम आप कर
सकते हैं चलिए ये तो हमने कर
लिया
अ ओके ओके
ग्रेट आउट ऑफ स्कोप व एबिलिटी को अगर बहुत
ज्यादा इंपैक्टफुल है तो रिपोर्ट कर सकते
हो अदर वाइज छोड़ देना कोई फायदा नहीं है
ठीक है यहां पे आपको हमने क्या सर्च किया
था id.com सर्च किया था नाउ वी हैव रड
ओजट सो लेट्स सी
लेट्स सर्च
फॉर रप ओज एंड यहां पे यहां पर हम सर्च
करते हैं डेटाबेस लेट्स सी व्हाट इ वी आर
गेटिंग कुछ भी नहीं मिला हमें ओज पे ट्स
टोटली फाइन neet.com इस पर सर्च करते हैं
यह भी इन्हीं का है सो लेट्स सर्च
neet.com
एंड ट्स इट ओके वी गट नथिंग कुछ भी हमें
नहीं मिला मेन इनका वेबसाइट
एक पासवर्ड भी कर लेता हूं एंड पास डब्लू
डी नहीं पासवर्ड छड़ा ह ह पासवर्ड डेटाबेस
हमने कर लिया था तो पासवर्ड में ओनली
पासवर्ड भी हमने कर लिया था शायद ओके सो
लेट्स सी हम यहां पर कुछ कीवर्ड यूज कर
लेते हैं बढ़िया सा
लाइक लेट्स टेक
ऑथराइजेशन
लेट्स एंड फॉर ऑथराइजेशन यर देन देन देन
देन देन देन देन कुछ और
कॉन्फिन फिग केलिए करते हैं
ओके डेटाबेस तो हमने कर लिया था डिप्लॉयड
डिजिटल ओन एसस की
बॉडी डॉट फाइल्स एड्स प है यह तो एड्स
लेटेड कर सकते हैं ड्रॉपलेट ट्रेविस
पासवर्ड एड्स का यूज हम कर सकते हैं कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है सो वी कैन यूज द एडब्ल्यू
एस कीवर्ड एड्स एक्सेस की आईडी यह वाली
चीज कर सकते हैं एक्सेस की आईडी
इफ वी गेट समथिंग ठीक है कुछ इस तरीके से
करके एंटर करते हैं एक बार रिजल्ट्स देखते
हैं क्या आता है हमारे
पास आर य गेटिंग एनी कोड ऑ नट वी आर नॉट
गेटिंग एनीथिंग सो लेट्स रिमूव एड्स
एक्सेस की आईडी यर कॉन्फिन फिग यहां पे
देखते
हैं लेट्स सी द
कॉन्फिन फिग का इलास्टिक लॉगिंग एंड एपीएम
ठीक है एक बार देख लेते हैं कोड में एक
मिला हमें
कुछ ठीक है हियर वी हैव व्हाट वी हैव
डिस्क्रिप्शन आई एम अ विंगर एट पॉलिटिशियन
हर्स विथ मोर ठीक है स्ट हेरो मेज अबाउट
मी हेलो आईम ठीक है भैया ये तो डिटेल इसके
डिटेल दे रहा है क्या है भाई ये ऑटोमेटेड
यहां पे रैपिड कंट्रोल एफ आर ए पी वाई डी
रैपिड का सर्च मारते हैं ये रहा अक्वायर्ड
बाय डफ नाउ रैपिड यह रहा ऑनलाइन पेमेंट
प्रोवाइडर अ पेंस एस वाज अक्वायर्ड बाय
फिटेक
लिटर इन 2016 नाउ रैपिड रैपिड है इनका नाम
अब ठीक है अच्छी बात है यहां पर कुछ मिल
रहा है क्या हमें नहीं कुछ खास य य बस
डिटेल्स है कुछ खास यहां है नहीं हमारे
पास तो जस्ट लीव
इट जस्ट लीव इट इसको छोड़ देते य पर य
हमारे कुछ खास काम का है नहीं ऑथराइजेशन
रिलेटेड ओनली एक बार सर्च कर लेते हैं
जस्ट
सर्च ओके ऑथराइजेशन प पाच कोड्स मिले हमें
भैया वी गट अभी हम ऑटोमेशन पर आएंगे थोड़ा
पेशेंस रखो वल कम टू ऑटोमेशन बत मतलब
ऑटोमेटेड टूल्स का यूज भी करके हम देखेंगे
तो य ऑथराइजेशन प कुछ है क्या यहां पे मेक
यो फर्स्ट एपीआई कॉल डॉक्यूमेंटेशन नॉट
नॉट डॉक्यूमेंटेशन है
ऑथराइजेशन एज यर ऑथराइजेशन इंटीग्रेशन दिस
इज अगेन सेम बंदा शायद अबाउट अबाउट वाला
है यह कोई बात नहीं क्रिस्टोफर देखते हैं
यह कनेक्टेड है क्या क्रिस्टोफर भाई इससे
रैपिड से या इन सबसे
कुछ
अच्छा जेपी ये शायद इन्होंने कुछ टेक ओवर
किया है आई थिंक ब ठीक है
ओके ओके कम्युनिटी कम्युनिटी नथिंग नथिंग
नथिंग नथिंग नथिंग मच कुछ है नहीं कुछ खास
है नहीं अब एक काम कर लेता हूं मैं यहां
पे बैकअप सर्च कर लेता हूं बैकअप से
रिलेटेड भी कुछ चीजें आपको मिल सकती है
जस्ट क्लिक ऑन बैकअप जल्दी से 10 के करवाओ
हां भाई जल्दी से 10 के करवाओ यार लाइक
मार दो लाइक ठोक दो यार कम से कम बैकअप से
रिलेटेड कुछ मिलती है तो नेट नेट बैकअप इज
नॉट
यर अच्छा कुछ यहां पे रिजल्ट्स मिले हैं
लेट्स सी द सीएसवी फाइल सीएसवी फॉर्मेट है
यह एंड यह क्या है यह लेट्स
सी टॉप साइट्स स्प्लिट ओके दैट इज अ
डिफरेंट थिंग कंट्रोल एफ रड नेट सीएसबी
फॉर्मेट में ये रड नेट आया बट ठीक है ये
नॉट अ सेंसिटिव
थिंग नॉट अ सेंसिटिव थिंग काइंड ऑफ ठीक है
सो कुछ यहां पे नहीं है लेट्स चेक सम अदर
कीवर्ड्स
हियर डीबी पास ड्डी वी कैन यूज दैट डीबी
पास
डब्डीसैक्स
ये रहने देते हैं क्योंकि इनको हमको
फिल्टर करना है 18 मिले यहां पे मेल टू
कम्युनिटी
rapidworkers.com लिकेज है ठीक है कोई बात
नहीं फोन नंबर इज हियर r.net
केवटी सो हियर वी गट सम ईमेल फोन
नंबर अच्छा यहां पे कुछ कुछ है यहां
पे हां आपको अगर कोई डिटेल भी लीकेज मिलती
है ना किसी किसी पर्टिकुलर यूजर की बहुत
ज्यादा डिटेल्स वगैरह मिल जा रही है कुछ
ऐसा वो भी आप रिपोर्ट कर सकते हैं ठीक
है इंफॉर्मेशन लीके इस के अंदर में एक्सेस
की न नॉट र रैपिड आर ए पवाई डी रापिड नेट
नथिंग कुछ खास नहीं है यहां
पे पेमेंट डिटेल्स ईमेल
ओके डाटा डेटा डाटा ईमेल यहां पे डिटेल्स
अच्छा एक बार ये
[संगीत]
कीवर्ड
ओके यहां
पर नथिंग मच कुछ खास यहां पर हमें मिल
नहीं रहा हमें कुछ खास य नहीं
मिला ठीक है नॉट गेटिंग मच ऑफ द
थिंग्स
या सो कुछ खास हमें यहां पे नहीं मिला है
नॉट नॉट मच ऑफ द थिंग्स ठीक है तो अगेन वी
कैन गो फॉर द डिफरेंट तो हम ऐसे करके क्या
कर सकते हैं अलग-अलग कीवर्ड्स के लिए
फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं ठीक
है एन आईटी एस एच है यार नितेश का
स्पेलिंग ठीक है चलो ये तो हमने देख लिया
यहां पे लॉग फाइल लॉग फाइल भी बहुत
सेंसिटिव हो सकती है लॉग फाइल के अंदर
आपको ना डिफरेंट डिफरेंट चीजें मिल सकती
है तो लॉग को भी आप जरूर सर्च कर लेना
एलजी एल
ओजी ले सी द लॉग कुछ मिलता है हमें तो
उसके अंदर लॉग हो जाते बहुत सारी चीज आपको
लॉग वाली मिल जाएगी ठीक है आपको समझ में
इतना तो शायद आ ही रहा होगा बहुत सिंपल है
कोई ज्यादा दिक्कत वाली बात यहां पर नहीं
है ठीक
है लॉग में कुछ मिला य चैनल यहां मिल रहा
है रैपिड पेमेंट्स अच्छा यह य चैनल कौन सा
है देखते हैं यह कौन सा यह काम करता है
क्या भाई रैपिड के पास रैपिड में काम करते
हो क्या
भाई अच्छा वेक्टर जोन य तो हट यार वेक्टर
लोगो जोन है य जस्ट क्लिक ऑन बैक क्लिक ऑन
बैक एट एंड
डन ओके मैक्स लॉग साइज
1000 किसके लिए है यह रापिड के लिए है
क्या नहीं है रप नेट रड ड नेट यरल पाथ ठीक
है स बॉक्स
नेनेने नथिंग नथिंग ने
नथिंग
यह क्या
है रैपिड एक्सेस
की
ओके सेम की ी गट सी एफ सी सी सी सी स
लास्ट 505 सी ओके
लेट्स इ द सेम थिंग य तो सेम है जो हमें
मिला था ठीक है बढ़िया है वही है एक ही है
मुझे लगा कोई और डुप्लीकेट है तो फिर
थोड़ा सा डिफरेंट हो जाता बट यह सेम है तो
अच्छी बात है लेट्स सी यहां पर एक्सेस की
हेयर इट
इज रप
नेट ठीक है तो यहां पर एक कुछ एक्सेस की
से रिलेटेड कुछ भी है क्या हमारे पास
न नथिंग इ यर कुछ भी नहीं है चलिए बढ़िया
बढ़िया पेमेंट हां पेमेंट सही है पेमेंट
भी लगा सकते हैं ल
सी यहां पर यह वाला mlb.com पासवर्ड यह
काफी अच्छा कीवर्ड होता हैड ml.com
पासवर्ड ठीक है यू कैन यूज दिस वन यह वाला
कीवर्ड आप यूज कर सकते
हैं लेट्स गिव इट अ
ट्राई इफ वी गेट
समथिंग ओके
नथिंग वी गट हियर तो आपको ये कीवर्ड्स यूज
करने इसी तरीके से पासवर्ड पास कोड यह
सारी चीजें कर लीजिए ओटीपी से रिलेटेड कुछ
करना है वो वाला आप कर सकते हैं कोई
स्पेसिफिक आपको टोकन वगैरह से रिलेटेड
करना है टोकन वगैरह आप कर सकते हैं
सीक्रेट सीक्रेट्स यह भी एक अच्छा कीवर्ड
है सीक्रेट तो सीक्रेट भी आप यूज कर सकते
हैं वी कैन यूज
सीक्रेट सीक्रेट यहां पर सीक्रेट सर्च
करेंगे यहां पर एंड लेट्स
वेट हेलो हेलो हेलो भैया सब कैसे हैं
यह रहा रैपिड एक्सेस की रैपिड सीक्रेट की
ये क्या है ये क्ला डट एसबीआई सस वाले
भैया हमारे कुछ है क्या इसके अंदर रैपिड
एक्सेस की सीक्रेट की के अंदर
में यहां पर इन्होने एक्सेस की सीक्रेट की
लिखा नहीं है इन्होंने बस यह लिख दिया है
कि एक्सेस की है सीक्रेट की है इन्होंने
वो चीज दी नहीं है एक बंदे ने वहां दे
दिया था एक्सेस की सीक की इसलिए हमने वहां
रिपोर्ट कर दिया यहां फिलहाल कुछ हमें मिल
नहीं रहा एजेक्ट प्लेन टेक्स्ट में तो कुछ
किसी ने इस बंदे ने भी नहीं लिखा हुआ है
इस बंदे ने डाला नहीं है तो यह समझदार
बंदा है अच्छा हुआ रिपोर्ट कर ही दिया है
देख लेते
हैं नॉट हियर यहां प भी एक्सेस सीक्रेट की
सीक्रेट की एक्सेस की लीकेज नहीं
है सीके टैक्सेस की दिस वन इज अनदर इज इट
द सेम सीक्रेट की यह सेम है ना
यार 1937 वाली यह सेम है क्या जो कि है 19
नहीं ये दूसरी है
75 सीएफ सीसी बीडी सीएफ नहीं ये दूसरी
एक्सेस की है चलो ठीक है कोई बात
नहीं बैक एंड मार्केट प्लेस का रैपिड
एपीआई यहां पर ये दे रखा है यहां
पे बंदे ने दिस वन इ आल्सो लेट्स सी लेट्स
सी लेट्स कीप इट एज अ बैकअप मैं इसको एज अ
बैकअप यहां पे डाल देता हूं रैपिड वाले
में गिट
रेकन लेट्स पुट इनसाइड दिस वन ए की लेट्स
पुट दिस वन ए दिस वन कंट्रोल s ट्स सॉरी
सॉरी
सॉरी यहां
पे ठीक
है ओके चलिए तो इस तरीके से ये तो आपका
मैनुअल अप्रोच आप मैनुअली कर रहे हैं मैं
आपको एक माइंडसेट भी बताया माइंडसेट क्या
बताया मैंने आपको कि आप गेट हब पे
रिपोजिटरीज फाइंड कीजिए वैसे जहां अब मान
लो जैसे आपको डेल के लिए फाइंड करना है
मान लो आप डेल के लिए फाइंड करो dell.com
के लिए तो अब फाइंड करो कि dell.com के
लिए कौन काम कर रहा है कोई पर्टिकुलर बंदा
है उसको फॉलो करो और उसके अपडेट्स के उसके
गिट हब के अपडेट्स पे जो भी चीजें करता है
उसको फॉलो करो और मॉनिटर करो हो सकता है
तुम्हें कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग स्टफ मिल जाए कुछ
डाटा मिल जाए ठीक है चलो ये तो आपको समझ
में आ गया ये मैनुअल अप्रोच था ठीक है ये
मैनुअल अप्रोच था ठीक है आपको समझ में आ
गया अब यहां पे हम आते हैं एक ऑटोमेटेड
अप्रोच पे ऑटोमेशन वाले अप्रोच पे एंड
उसको पहले हम देखते हैं ऑटोमेशन अप्रोच पे
ऑटोमेशन अप्रोच कर के लिए हमें टूल्स यूज
करने हैं देर आर मल्टीपल टूल्स अवेलेबल
ठीक है एंड कीवर्ड्स के बारे में जो बातें
मैंने बताई आपको कीवर्ड्स के बारे में तो
ऑलरेडी मैंने आपको बता ही दिया बहुत सारे
कीवर्ड्स अवेलेबल है एक उसमें से एक ये
कीवर्ड मास्टर कीवर्ड जो है यह वाला जो है
यह वाला हमारे पास यहां पे अवेलेबल है ठीक
है चलिए भैया अब यहां पे हम क्या करते हैं
ऑटोमेटेड टूल का यूज करते हैं ऑटोमेटेड
टूल में मैं यहां पे बाकी चीजें सारी
चीजें बंद कर देता हूं इफ वी गेट सम
रिप्लाई
कोई रिप्लाई है क्या कोई रिप्लाई नहीं है
ठीक है हटाओ यहां पर चलते हैं इसको बंद कर
देते हैं एंड यहां पर ऑटोमेटेड की में हम
हम यहां पर ऑटोमेशन में क्या करते
हैं ठीक है हम य ऑटोमेशन में पहले क्या कर
देते हैं हमारे पास बहुत सारे टूल्स
अवेलेबल है ठीक है दे मल्टीपल टूल्स
अवेलेबल आप सब देखिए मैं आपको आप सबको एक
चीज बता देता हूं कितने लोग है य पर 61
61 लोग ही है ओनली यार क्या है यार ऐसे
कैसे तुम लोग करते हो यार ये तुम लोग
क्यों कर रहे हो ऐसा सि 61 लोग है यहां पर
लाइक ठोक दो सभी लोग लाइक ठोक दिया क्या
अरे लाइक तो दंबा के हुआ है लाइकिंग क्या
बात है यार चलो बढ़िया है यार बढ़िया है
चलिए तो अब यहां पर हम चलते हैं व्ट वी आर
गोइंग टू डू वी आर गोइंग टू यूज सम
ऑटोमेटेड टूल्स एंड टूल्स में सबसे पहला
जो टूल है आपका वह हम यूज करने वाले हैं
गिट
डॉकर गट डॉकर ठीक है तो गट डॉकर जो है यह
टूल हम यूज करेंगे और दिस इज अ वेरी
इंटरेस्टिंग टूल गट डकर एंड यहां पे आपको
मिल जाएगा गिट डॉकर इस तरीके से यहां पे
दिख सकता है देख सकते हैं आप गट डकर इज अ
टूल दैट यूटिलाइजेज गब सच एपीआई एंड
एक्सटेंसिव लिस्ट ऑफ़ गिट हब डॉक्स दैट आई
हैव कंपाइल्ड फ्रॉम वेरियस सोर्सेस टू
प्रोवाइड एन ओवरव्यू ऑफ़ सेंसिटिव
इंफॉर्मेशन स्टोर्ड ऑन गिब गिवन अ सर्च
क्वेरी एक सर्च क्वेरी के लिए पर्टिकुलर
यह आपको निकाल के देगा लेकिन इसमें क्या
है थोड़े से कैचेज हैं आपको समझने पेंगे
ठीक है आपको थोड़ा समझना पड़ेगा गिट डॉकर
को गट डॉकर को यूज करने के लिए आपको समझना
पड़ेगा पहले क्या सबसे पहले तो हम अपना
मशीन कनेक्ट कर लेते हैं मशीन कनेक्ट करने
के लिए हम यहां पर जो यूज कर रहे हैं वो
यूज कर रहे हैं क्या मोबा एक्सटम हम इसको
यूज कर रहे हैं सेशन को सेशन हमारा क्लोज
हो चुका है
ओबवियसली तो यहां पे ओबवियसली इससे हम
बाहर आ जाते हैं यह सेम आईपी है दो दो बन
चुके हैं इसको मैं डिलीट सेशन इसको मैं
डिलीट कर देता हूं पहला जो सेशन है इस पर
चलते हैं एंड इसको वापस से एग्जीक्यूट कर
देते सेशन को यहां पर पासवर्ड डाल देते
हैं हम अपने वीपीएस क्लाउड सर्विस
से इंटरेक्ट कर रहे हैं भाई हम लोग यहां
पर थोड़ा मैं इंक्रीज कर देता हूं इसका
साइज ट्स इट अब चलिए यहां प देखते हैं गिट
ड्रकर को कैसे यूज करना है इसको
इंस्टॉलेशन पहले देखते हैं इंस्टॉलेशन
कैसे करनी है भैया
[संगीत]
तो नीचे आ जाओ इंस्टॉलेशन का दे रखा
है डॉकर के साथ भी कर सकते हैं वैसे भी कर
सकते हैं नॉर्मली इंस्टॉलेशन का कुछ दे
नहीं रखा है गट क्लोन करना
पड़ेगा चलिए गिट क्लोन कर लेते हैं जब कुछ
नहीं दिया हो तो गिट क्लोन कर लीजिए यहां
पे एंड यहां पे गिट क्लोन करके आपने यहां
गिट क्लोन कमांड लगा देना है ठीक है सिंपल
सा फंडा है इसको मैं फुल स्क्रीन कर लेता
हूं f11
से
सॉरी यहां पे कर देते हैं गिट क्लोन एंड
हियर वी आर पेस्टिंग द लिंक यह क्या फालतू
चीज आ गई भाई इसमें लिंक में कॉपी होके
चलो इसको रिमूव कर देते हैं यहां पे गेट
क्लोन हमारा जो लिंक है वो कॉपी किया एंड
यहां पे क्लोन कर लेते हैं गडकर इज क्लोन
अ यहां एलएस करेंगे यहां पे आपको गट डकर
डायरेक्टरी मिल जाएगी इसके अंदर चल च चले
चलते हैं गट डर के अंदर में यहां एलएस
करते हैं एलएस करोगे तो यहां पे एक
रिक्वायरमेंट t एकटी फाइल है गाइ यानी कि
रिक्वायरमेंट इंस्टॉल करनी है तो अच्छी
बात है कर लेते हैं क्या हमारा क्या जाता
है तो क्या करना है पिप अ पिप 3 इंस्टॉल h
r
requirement.txt आपको ये एरर आ रही है दिस
एनवायरमेंट इज एक्सटर्नली मैनेज ये एरर
किसी को आती है पिप से इंस्टॉल करने के
लिए करते हैं तब ये एरर किसी को आई है
पहले जब आपने पिप से इंस्टॉल करने की
कोशिश की है किसी रिक्वायरमेंट्स को आपके
साथ ये एरर आई है क्या दिस एनवायरमेंट इज
एक्सटर्नली मैनेज्ड ऐसा कुछ करके
एक्सटर्नली मैनेज एनवायरमेंट के लिए
वीपीएस में मोस्टली आपके देखने को मिल
सकती
है बताइए
मुझे
प्लीज लेट मी
नो नो सर नो नो सर ठीक है नहीं आई है किसी
को एक को तो नहीं आई
है अच्छा वीपीएस में अगर आप यूज करें तो
मे भी शायद आपको आ जाए ठीक है तो पिप थ से
आप करेंगे तो य कमांड बिल्कुल सही है बट
अगर आपको इस तरह की एरर आती है इसका मतलब
आपको एक वर्चुअल एनवायरमेंट क्रिएट करना
पड़ेगा ठीक है ये देखो यहां
प वर्चुअल एनवायरमेंट क्रिएट करना पड़ेगा
इफ यू वांट टू इंस्टॉल ए नॉन डेविन पैकेज
python2 टू अ यूजिंग python3 ठीक है देन
जाके अ जो है आप इसको यूज़ कर सकते हैं
अदर वाइज़ आप मैनुअली भी इंस्टॉल कर सकते
हैं दोनों तरीके से देखो जैसे मैनुअली
करने का मतलब क्या हुआ मान लो पिप 3 वाला
कमांड यह नहीं काम कर रहा तुम्हें एरर आ
रही है तो तुम अब क्या करो कट
requirement.txt इसके अंदर जो भी
रिक्वायरमेंट्स हो उसको देख लो और इसको
मैनुअली इंस्टॉल कर सकते हो कैसे
python3
अह python3 होगा
कैसे इंस्टॉल करते हैं एप्ट एप्ट इंस्टॉल
python3 एंड देन जो आपका मॉड्यूल है उसको
इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं जैसे टर्म कलर टर्म
कलर इस तरीके से तो आपने किया यहां पे
इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा उसके बाद टी क्यूडीएम है
टी क्यूडीएम टी क्यूडीएम इस तरीके से आपका
इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा उसके बाद रिक्वेस्ट है
तो पाइथन 3 आर आर ई क यूई एस टी एस
रिक्वेस्ट इस तरीके से आपका इंस्टॉल हो
जाएगा यह तो आपका एक तरीका हो
गया दूसरा तरीका बताता हूं कि पिप नहीं
मुझे पिप 3 कमांड ही लगाना है भाई मुझे ये
सब चीजें नहीं करनी पिप 3 कमांड से
इंस्टॉल करना है तो सिंपल इसका क्या कमांड
है पिप 3 इंस्टॉल h r requirement.txt बस
यही कमांड है इससे एग्जीक्यूट होना चाहिए
एंटर करूंगा ये एरर आ रही है जब ये एरर आ
रही है इसका मतलब है ये आपको एक वर्चुअल
एनवायरमेंट क्रिएट करना पड़ेगा पिप चलाने
के लिए एंड देन आप ये कर सकते हैं उसके
लिए क्या करना पड़ेगा आपको सिंपली ये
कमांड लगाना है python3 h m v एवी
एनवायरमेंट वाला वर्चुअल एनवायरमेंट का
क्या करना है
python3 ठीक है यह आपको डाल देना उसके बाद
हान ए वी एनवायरमेंट जो वर्चुअल
एनवायरमेंट है वो दे दीजिए और पाथ टू वी
एनवायरमेंट उस एनवायरमेंट का जो भी पाथ है
वो पाथ आपको मेंशन करना है कोई भी पाथ दे
सकते हैं मैं करेंटली ी एवी ए एनवी भी दे
सकता हूं या कोई और भी नाम से दे सकता हूं
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है तो मैं मैं यहां प
देखता हूं वी एनवी वी एनवी ठीक है हो गया
एंड यहां पे पाथ वी एनवी पाथ नाम दे देना
है कुछ भी दे सकते हो या सिंपल व एंड व रख
लो कोई दिक्कत नहीं सॉरी मैंने यहां पर
एंटर कर दिया
हो गया डन अब मैं एलएस करूंगा तो यहां पर
एक आपको वी एनवी पाथ नाम की डायरेक्टरी बन
जाएगी अब इसके अंदर जाओगे तो कुछ चीजें
मिलेगी जैसे वी एनवी पाथ चलो वी
एनवी एलस करो तो यहां पे अलग-अलग फाइल्स
डायरेक्टरीज बनी है बिन इंक्लूड लिब लि 64
पी वाई वी ए एनवी सीएफजी कॉन्फिन फाइल
इसकी मिली हुई है ठीक है जब तुमने यहां
बना ली तो अब जो तुम्हें एरर आई थी मैंने
हमेशा बोला है ना जो एरर आती है उसी पर
आपको सॉल्यूशन भी मिल जाता है आपको थोड़ा
दिमाग लगाएंगे तो अब यहां पे आपको कमांड
चलाना है क्या पाथ टू वी एनवी विन पाइथन
इस तरीके से बस सिंपल सा ये कमांड चला
देना है एंड पाथ टू वी एन बी पप दैट्ची है
तो आपको बस ये वाली चीज कर देनी है एंड
दैट्ची पाथ टू बिन तो यहां पे बिन का पाथ
क्या है भैया वई एनवी पाथ हो गया आपका ठीक
है उसके बाद इसमें है बिन और इसमें है एक
एक्टिवेट ये वाला फाइल इसको एंटर करना है
एंड
दैट्ची एनवायरमेंट पाथ अब आप गुड टू गो
हैं एलएस करेंगे अब रिक्वायरमेंट
tt3 इंस्टॉल h r requirement.txt और एंटर
करेंगे आपका रिक्वायरमेंट जो पहले जैसे
नॉर्मल काली में आप चलाते हैं वैसे आपका
चलना शुरू हो जाएगा और रिक्वायरमेंट्स
आपकी इंस्टॉल हो जाएगी सिंपल ठीक है गॉट
इट द साइबर रिसर्चर मैं बढ़िया आप
बताओ
चलिए तो यहां पे आपको समझ में आ गया होगा
अब आप वी वर्चुअल एनवायरमेंट पाथ में आ
चुके हैं वी हैव सक्सेसफुली इंस्टॉल्ड
मुझे इससे बाहर आना है सिंपल डीएक्टिवेट
लिख दीजिए एंटर कर दीजिए आप उस एनवायरमेंट
से बाहर आ जाते हैं एंड यू आर नाउ आउट ऑफ
द एनवायरमेंट एलएस करते हैं हमारा
इंस्टॉलमेंट रिक्वायरमेंट हो चुका है अब
मुझे इसको एग्जीक्यूट करना है तो
थ एंड गट डक पवा हाफ एंड h तो ये इस तरीके
से एग्जीक्यूट हो जाता है अब काम कैसे
करना है देखिए हेल्प फाइल देख के ही आपको
सीख लेना है कहीं जाने की जरूरत नहीं है
नडी डॉक्स अगर आपके पास डॉक्स की लिस्ट है
तो डॉक्स यहां पे दे दीजिए तो ओबवियसली
हमारे पास डॉक्स की लिस्ट आई थिंक इसके
पास ऑलरेडी है यहां देखिए डॉक इसका खुद का
डॉक का लिस्ट है यहां पे डॉक्स सीडी डॉक्स
एलएस करते हैं यहां पे एक ऑल डॉक्स वर्जन
3 है एक मीम d.ts है ये दोनों डॉक्स हैं
चलिए यहां पे देख लेते हैं कैट मीयम डग्स
कितने हैं इसमें डॉग्स 240 है और इसमें
कितने हैं ऑल डॉग्स
में ऑल डॉक्स में इसमें है 513 513 है
इसमें डॉक्स उसमें जो है 240 है चलिए 240
वाला ही यूज करेंगे मीडियम अंडर डॉक्सड
मीडियम अंड डॉक्स यह वाला हमारा फाइल नेम
है ठीक है बढ़िया नाउ वी आर गुड टू यूज
दिस
टूल तो हम क्या
करेंगे कहां गया
भैया ये रहा
हां ये आपको समझ में आ रहा है सब कुछ अब
हम यहां पे क्या करेंगे python3 गड
दे दिया या उसका नाम क्वेरी कोई स्ट्रिंग
दे दिया कुछ भी दे सकते हैं क्वेरी फाइल
यहां पर है एक लाइक एक कोई क्वेरी फाइल
आपके पास है लाइक कोई लिस्ट ऑफ डोमस है
उसको क्वेरी करना है उसके रिपोजिटरीज को
तो आप कर सकते हैं ठीक है उसके बाद यहां
पे हाइन एल भी है लिमिट बायपास ठीक है
बेसिकली क्या है इंक्रीजस रिक्वेस्ट पर
मिनट व्हेन यूजिंग मल्टीपल टोकेंस फ्रॉम
यूनिक अकाउंट्स ठीक है तो अब देखो यहां पर
एक लफड़ा है वो क्या लफड़ा है मैं आपको
समझाता
हूं
मजा आ रहा है सबको पहले ही बता दीजिए मजा
आ रहा है कि नहीं आ रहा सीखने को मिल रहा
है कि नहीं मिल रहा कुछ बढ़िया कंटेंट अब
ये एलबी का कम काम मैं क्यों कर यूज में
लूंगा मैं आपको बताता हूं बहुत यहां पर
लफड़ा है बहुत लफड़ा फसने वाला है देखते
जाओ अभी क्या लफड़ा फसने वाला है वो मैं
आपको अभी बताऊंगा ठीक है अब हम क्या करते
हैं य हान टी यहां पे टोकन के लिए हान
टीएफ यहां पर टोकन फाइल के लिए है ठीक है
अब गिट हब पे जब आप टूल्स का यूज करेंगे
तो भैया गिट हब आपको बोलता है गिट हब आपको
बोलता है कि टूल्स का यूज आप नहीं कर सकते
हैं सबसे पहली बात टूल्स का यूज करेंगे तो
आपको एपीआई क्वेरीज जो करते हैं उसमें एक
लिमिटेशन है गिट हब की जो एपीआई क्वेरीज
है एपीआई क्वेरी यानी देखो यह क्या करेगा
टूल यह टूल गिट हब के एपीआई को ही तो
क्वेरी करेगा समझ में आ एपीआई को क्वेरी
करेगा अब एपीआई को यानी एपीआई को जब
क्वेरी कोई करता है तो उसकी एक लिमिटेशन
होती है मान लो आपसे कोई सवाल पूछा जाए
मैं आपसे एक सवाल पूछता हूं तुम्हारा नाम
क्या है तुम अपना नाम बता दोगे अब मैं
तुमसे बार बार यही सवाल पूछ तुम्हारा नाम
के तुम बाद में इरिटेट हो जाओगे तुम
बोलोगे नहीं तुम सिर्फ पांच बार ही मुझसे
पूछ सकते हो सवाल उसके बाद
पूछोगे तो पैसा लगेगा सीधी सी बात है तो
हर एक सर्विस प्रोवाइडर जो होती है वो
फ्री एपीआई क्वेरीज का लिमिटेशन कर देती
है ठीक है पहली बात गिट हब के अंदर में
क्या है यह 30
रिक्वेस्ट 30 रिक्वेस्ट पर मिनट यहां पे
इनकी एक लिमिटेशन है एक काइंड ऑफ गिट की
फ्री वाली की मैं बात कर रहा हूं एपीआई की
यहां पे 30 रिक्वेस्ट पर मिनट ठीक है इससे
ज्यादा जाओगे एपीआई लिमिटेशन आ जाएगा एंड
आपकी रिक्वेस्ट फुलफिल नहीं हो पाएगी आप
क्वेरी नहीं कर पाओगे एपीआई को एपीआई को
क्वेरी क्यों करनी है भैया क्योंकि तभी तो
वो पर्टिकुलर रिपोजिटरी या पर्टिकुलर कुछ
इंटरेस्टिंग स्टफ खोज के ये टूल निकाल के
देंगे समझ में आ रहा है ठीक है ठीक है ठीक
है समझ में आ रहा है ये समझ में आ गया ये
30 रिक्वेस्ट पर मिनट क्या करके और वो
निकाल के आपको देंगे 30 रिक्वेस्ट पर मिनट
अब चलिए यहां पे अब हम यहां पे समझते हैं
इसका यूज केस क्या है चलिए अब आ आते हैं
यहां पे गिट
पे गिट पे आ जाते हैं अब इस टूल के लिए
आपको एपीआई की कॉन्फिन करनी पड़ेगी बिना
एपीआई की कॉन्फिन किए आप नहीं यूज कर सकते
एपीआई की कैसे कॉन्फिन है गिट हब का एपीआई
की कैसे निकालना है आप सबको पता है मैंने
बताया हुआ है सिंपल आपके अकाउंट में लॉगइन
कर लेना है अकाउंट पे यहां पे जाना है
यहां पे आपको चलना है अ सेटिंग्स पे ठीक
है यहां पे सेटिंग्स पे आ गए सेटिंग्स पे
जब आप आएंगे तो नीचे आएंगे यहां पे तो
यहां पे डेवलपर सेटिंग्स मिलेगा डेवलपर
सेटिंग्स पे आ जाइएगा डेवलपर सेटिंग्स पे
आएंगे तो पर्सनल एक्सेस टोकन मिलेगा यहां
पे क्लासिक टोकन प आ जाइएगा ठीक है यहां
पे पहले से कुछ एपीआई की यहां पे बने हुए
हैं मेरे पास मैं एक और एपीआई की बना के
आपको दिखा देता हूं जस्ट जनरेट अ न्यू
टोकन क्लासिक यहां पे यहां पे पासवर्ड
मांग रहा है तो मैं यहां पे पासवर्ड दे
देता हूं एंड फिर से लॉगइन कर लेता हूं अब
यहां पे मैं कर देता हूं गेट हब रिकन
सिक्स सिक्स नंबर जो है वो बना लेता हूं
सिक्स ठीक है सिक्स यहां पे आपका यह सारे
टिक कर दीजिएगा जो भी यहां पे ऑप्शंस है
जस्ट टिक इट टिक इट ठीक ठीक टिक मारो भैया
टिक मारो
एंजॉय मजे करो टिक मारते जाओ सारे फीचर्स
सारे सर्विसेस के लिए इनेबल कर देगा इस
पर्टिकुलर एपीआई क्वेरीज को और यह सारी
चीजें आप क्वेरीज कर सकते हो ठीक है ना अ
जनरेट टोकन जनरेट टोकन कर देंगे आपके पास
टोकन जनरेट हो जाएगा यहां पे कॉपी कर
लीजिए एक बार कॉपी कर लीजिए दोबारा यह
आपको देखने को नहीं मिलेगा दोबारा आपको
जनरेट ही करना पड़ेगा तो मेरे पास यहां पे
ऑलरेडी यहां पे कुछ जेनरेटेड टोकन है
मैंने यहां पे डाल दिया फिर से इस वाले
टोकन को भी ठीक है भैया चलिए अब जो है जब
आप इस टोकन को जनरेट कर लेंगे ना आपको इस
टोकन को यहां पे आके
कंफिट में बिना उसके किए आप नहीं यूज कर
सकते हैं कैसे आपको करना पड़ेगा मैं आपको
दिखा देता हूं यहां ध्यान दे लीजिए एक बार
प्लीज यहां पर मैं एलएस करता
हूं यहां
पे एलस किया यहां पे आपको एक फाइल मिलेगी
टीएफ डायरेक्टरी मिलेगी एक इस डायरेक्टरी
में चल देते हैं टीएफ एलएस करेंगे टोकन
फाइल ठीक है टोकन फाइल इस टोकन फाइल में
आपको टोकन को कंफिल कर देना है ठीक है तो
मैं क्या करता हूं कैट टोकन फाइल करता हूं
अभी फिलहाल इसके अंदर कुछ भी नहीं है मैं
इसके अंदर ये फाइल ये जो है एंट्रीज
करूंगा तो विम से मैं इसको ओपन कर लेता
हूं एंड यहां पे मैं क्या कर देता हूं जो
मेरा टोकन फाइल है उसको कॉपी कर लेता हूं
अब यहां पे एक चीज ध्यान देने वाली है मैं
क्या मैंने क्या किया एक टोकन को यहां पे
कॉपी किया यहां पे विम में यहां पे लाके
पेस्ट कर दिया मैंने एक टोकन ये कॉपी किया
है अब जब मैं इस टूल को यूज करूंगा ना तो
जब ये एक टोकन यूज करेगा जब इसकी
रिक्वेस्ट जो मैक्सिमम लिमिट है वो जब
कंप्लीट हो जाएगी तो एरर आनी शुरू हो
जाएगी कि एपीआई रिक्वेस्ट लिमिट रीज तो
मैं मल्टीपल टोकेंस को यहां पे कन्फर कर
दूंगा तो टूल क्या करेगा एक टोकन से जब
उसका रिक्वेस्ट फुलफिल हो जाएगा तो दूसरे
से जाएगा दूसरे के बाद तीसरे पे जाएगा
चौथे पे जाएगा ऐसे करके राउंड राउंड राउंड
राउंड वो घूमता रहेगा एंड लेस चांसेस कि
आपको जो लिमिट है वो आपको रीच आउट करेगी
स्टिल कर जाती है तो कोई बात नहीं टाइम
आउट लगा के थोड़ा हम रुक सकते हैं
थोड़ा-थोड़ा वेट कर करके सर्च कर सकते हैं
ठीक है तो हमने एक टोकन यहां पे लगा दिया
चलिए मल्टीपल टोकन लगाते
हैं यहां पे मल्टीपल टोकन लगा देते
हैं कंट्रोल
सी एंड
हियर पेस्ट दैट इट ठीक है तो हमने पांचों
के पांचों कितने एक दोती च पा छह टोकन को
हमने कन्फर कर दिया एक साथ में यहां पे
कॉलन डबल क सेव एंड एग्जिट कर देते हैं
दैट्ची अगेन अब हमें लॉन्च करना है हमारा
सेम कमांड हमारा जो है उसको लच करना है
यहां पे हान h देख लीजिए अब यहां पे जब आप
लच करेंगे तो आपको क्या करना है डॉट पवा
हमने कर दिया अब हियर वी हैव टू गिव अ
लिस्ट ऑफ डॉक्स तो हाइ फन डी दे देते हैं
डॉक के लिए तो डॉक का ऑलरेडी फोल्डर है
एंड यहां पे मीडियम वाली डॉक थी ना क्या
नाम था उसका यार
ओके क्या नाम था अ डॉक
मीयम ठीक है तो हमने यहां पर हान डीड मीड
यह वाली डॉक दे दी ठीक है डॉक वाली हमने
दे दी उसके बाद डॉक लगा दिया हाइन क
क्वेरी के लिए है हम वह भी दे देंगे
क्वेरी फाइल भी दे देंगे कोई है तो ठीक है
और कुछ तो है नहीं यहां पे समझ में आ रहा
है आप ध्यान दीजिएगा ठीक
है प्लीज आप लोग ध्यान दीजिएगा इधर प्लीज
आप लोग थोड़ा सा इधर ध्यान दीजिए जब आप
डॉक का मेंशन कर देंगे आपको एक टोकन फाइल
भी यहां पर या तो आप टोकन दे दीजिए टोकन
फाइल आप लगा दीजिए ठीक है तो टोकन फाइल हम
देते हान टीएफ टोकन फाइल का क्या हान टीएफ
ओनली तो हान टीएफ देते हैं ए यहां पर टोकन
फाइल का लोकेशन जो आपका टोकन फाइल है टोकन
फाइल टेक्स्ट जो फाइल थी व वाली आपने दे
दी उसके बाद आपको यहां पर हान क्य आपको
हान क्य देना हान क क्यों देना है क्वेरी
के लिए ठीक है भैया अब क्वेरी क्या करना
है तो हान क हमने दे दिया अब हमें करना है
रैपिड डॉट नेट यह वाली क्वेरी करनी है
रापिड नेट ठीक है ऐसे ही कुछ है आप यहां
पर वैसे चेक आउट कर सकते
हैं
टूल गिट डरकर गिट
डरकर यह वाली कुछ इस तरीके का इसका यूज
केस यहां पर एक बार चेक आउट कर लेते हैं
वैसे हमने सही दिया है हां जी टोकन फाइल अ
क्वेरी कर ली हमने डॉकर डॉक फाइल दे दी
हमने उसके बाद हा फन रिजल्ट आप सेव कर
सकते हैं एक पर्टिकुलर अ किसी भी फाइल के
अंदर में ठीक है हमें अभी कुछ नहीं करना
हमें फिलहाल स्क्रीन पे ही चाहिए तो हम
स्क्रीन पे ही ले लेते हैं ठीक है चलिए
हान आउटपुट के लिए
अ
ओके ओके पॉजिटिव रिजल्ट्स डिस्प्ले
पॉजिटिव रिजल्ट्स ओनली आप लगा सकते हैं
सिर्फ पॉजिटिव रिजल्ट्स के लिए थ्रेड्स को
आप बढ़ा सकते हैं डिफॉल्ट जो थ्रेड है वन
है अभी रहने देते हैं कोई बढ़ाने की जरूरत
हमें नहीं है एंड उसके बाद हान एलबी लिमिट
बायपास ठीक है लिमिट बायपास आप कर सकते
हैं हान एलबी जरूर लगा दीजिएगा ताकि आपका
जो लिमिट बायपास है वो वाला टेंशन खत्म हो
जाए आपका लिमिट बायपास जो है वो हो जाए तो
यह वाला आपकी यह वाली जो है यह वाली कमांड
है आपकी पूरी सिंपल सा ये कमांड हो गया अब
हम इस पे एंटर कर सकते हैं लेट्स सी व्हाट
इज गोइंग टू हैपन सो लेट्स प्रेस एंटर एंड
यहां देख सकते हैं 240 यूआरएल यूआरएल
जनरेट छह टोकेंस बीइंग यूज्ड 179
रिक्वेस्ट पर मिनट अब देखो यहां पे यह
देखो रेट लिमिट रेट लिमिट आ गई रेट लिमिट
रेट लिमिट रेट लिमिट आ गई तो मतलब रेट
लिमिट आपका लग गया अब यहां पे थोड़ी-थोड़ी
वेट करके भी यह करेगा बट यहां पे फिलहाल
आपको रेट लिमिट लग चुका है यहां पे यह
बहुत ही क्या है गिट हब का एक सेकंड लेयर
ऑफ आप सिक्योरिटी बोल सकते हैं एपीआई के
लिए कुछ ज्यादा ही ज्यादा ही इफोर्स कर
दिया है जिसकी वजह से रेट लिमिट यहां पे
आपके बेसिकली आ जा रहे हैं
दैट्ची है बाकी हमें स्टार्टिंग में यहां
पे इसने स्टार्ट किया था एंड यहां पे कोई
रेट लिमिट फिलहाल यहां पे कुछ डॉर्किंग कर
रहा था यहां पे 1679 रिक्वेस्ट पर मिनट
अलाउड यहां पे जो हमने इंक्रीज किया है
उसकी वजह से बट ठीक है हम यहां
पे अब इसमें अच्छा एक अच्छा एक क्या होगा
आपका स्टेप क्या होगा एक बढ़िया स्टेप
क्या होगा कि आप यहां पे
2530 जो है ना आप जनरेट कीजिए 253 एपीआई
जनरेट कीजिए ये चार पांच एपीआई से नहीं
होगा पांच छ एपीआई से नहीं होने वाला है
जनरली 253 एपीआई जनरेट कीजिए एंड उन एपीआई
को कन्फर कीजिए एंड देन आप इसको यूज यूज
कीजिए ठीक है अब यहां पे देखो यहां पे 50
ये अब क्या है स्लीपिंग टू अवॉइड रेट
लिमिट्स इतने देर के बाद ये क्या है
स्लीपिंग में जा रहा है कि रेट लिमिट को
अवॉइड किया जाए कुछ इतने सेकंड के बाद
वापस से ये स्टार्ट होगा ताकि रेट लिमिट
को थोड़ा अवॉइड किया जा सके दैट्ची चर लगा
रखा है इन्होंने बाकी और ऐसा कुछ नहीं है
तो हमें इतना वेट करना पड़ेगा फिर देखते
हैं फिर क्या होता है राइट लेट्स
सी लेट्स सी लेट्स
[संगीत]
सी
ओके देखते जाइए यहां
पे
[संगीत]
ट आज बहुत कम लोग हैं पता नहीं सब लोग घूम
रहे हैं आज घूमने गए हैं सब लोग भैया
घूमने दे आर घूमि घूमि
अगेन यहां पर स्टार्ट हुआ एंड अगेन यहां
पर वी गट सम रेट लिमिट थिंग इस तरीके से
मतलब कुछ रेट लिमिट थिंग्स आ रही है यहां
पर चलिए एक बार कंप्लीट इसको पहले हो जाने
देते हैं देन लेट्स
सी लेट्स सी लेट्स
सी ओके यहां पर कुछ हमें यहां पर हमें
रिजल्ट मिल चुके हैं जितने भी इसने फाइंड
किए हैं एंड यहां जब आप पे जाएंगे ऊपर की
तरफ यहां पे इस तरीके से तो रिजल्ट्स यहां
पे मिल र हैं ये सक्सेस वाले रिजल्ट्स हैं
जो आपको ग्रीन में दिख रहे हैं ये हैश में
दिख रहे हैं न्यूट्रल है नो रिजल्ट्स
रिटर्न की तरह से ठीक है एंड यहां पे आपको
फेलियर वाले हैं तो ग्रीन वाले देखते हैं
यहां पे डॉक एसएफ यूजर नेम सेल्स फोर्स
एंड यहां पे कुछ मिला है यहां पे gap.com
सर्च ऐसा कुछ करके यहां पे रिजल्ट्स यहां
पे कुछ भी नहीं है यहां पे रिजल्ट्स है
डॉक के लिए एक्सेस की के लिए 95 रिजल्ट्स
आपको मिले हैं इस एक्सेस की के लिए चलिए
बढ़िया है यहां पे एक्सेस की के लिए हमें
95 रिजल्ट्स मिले हैं तो लेट्स
लेट्स ओपन
इट
ओके
अ एक्सेस की के लिए
rapid.com करके निकाल दिया यहां पे अब
यहां एक्सेस की से रिलेटेड यहां पे
कुछ-कुछ डिटेल्स यहां पे मिले हैं अब आप
इनको मैनुअली सर्च कर सकते हैं मैनुअली
क्या कर सकते हैं सर्च करके देख सकते हैं
भाई क्या है इसके अंदर क्या है कुछ ऐसा तो
नहीं है अब देखो यहां
पे पायल पात्रा लेट्स
सी अ इन्होंने कुछ किया है पायल पात्रा
इससे रिलेटेड टू रैपिड अ इनका रिलेटेड है
क्या रैपिड से एफ आईएस ग्लोबल मे बी कुछ
हो सकता है भुवनेश्वर इंडिया
एंड कुछ ना कुछ रिलेशन हो सकता है पायल
पात्रा तो इनको हम सर्च कर लेंगे एक बार
पायल पात्रा जी को लिंकन पर शायद
एसोसिएटेड
हो सॉरी सीनियर एडिटर है
यह दिल्ली
यूनिवर्सिटी ट ट ट ट न्यूरोसाइंस क्या य
यह कोई और पल बत रहा है डिजिटल
ट्रांसफॉर्मेशन
मैनेजर
हां यह हो सकती
है नस एंड यंग ग्लोबल कंसल्टिंग सर्विसेस
या आई थिंक सेम हैदराबाद तेलंगाना नहीं
डिफरेंट है
यार चलो ठीक है इस मतलब आप सर्च कर लेना
इस तरीके से बाकी हमें कुछ रिजल्ट मिले
यहां पर वी कैन सी दैट
अगेन वी हैव सम मोर रिजल्ट लेट्स
सी एन एड्स के कुछ रिजल्ट य मिले 20
रिजल्ट यहां पर मिले एपीआई सीक्रेट के
नहीं मिले एपीआई की के हमें मिले हैं ओ
एपीआई की के हमें 12 रिजल्ट मिले हैं तो
वी विल नॉट मिस इट लेट्स सी क्या 12
रिजल्ट है एपीआई की
के मैनुअल इज बेस्ट मैंने आपको पहले ही
बोला था वो तो मैंने आपको पहले बोला था ना
मैनुअल बेस्ट है लेकिन इसमें क्या हो ना
जब आप ऑटोमेशन कर रहे हो एक तरह से देखो
क्या बात क्या है जब ऑटोमेट किया ना तो
मैनुअल में जब उतनी चीजें खोजो तुम एक-एक
कीवर्ड डाल के खोजो यहां टूल ने क्या किया
देखो बात को थोड़ा समझो मैं क्या समझाना
चाह रहा हूं उस चीज को थोड़ा समझने की
कोशिश करो यहां टूल ने वो सारे जैसे इस
पर्टिकुलर
टोकन मतलब इस पर्टिकुलर डॉग के लिए कितने
रिजल्ट्स है दो रिजल्ट्स है तो आप खोले और
देख लिया अब मान लो इसमें कोई रिजल्ट ही
नहीं है तो ये तुम सर्च करोगे तो वहां
मैनुअल में टाइम वेस्ट हो गया ऑटोमेशन ने
क्या किया फट से निकाल के तुम्हें दे दिया
पर्टिकुलर चीज के लिए ठीक है तो एपीआई की
के लिए 12 रिजल्ट्स हमें मिले हैं लेट्स
फाइंड आउट व्हाट इज द एपीआई के
रिजल्ट्स ये देखो टेस्ट एडमिन ये देखा
टेस्ट एडमिन वाला टेस्ट वाला है ये एपीआई
की तो हमें नहीं चाहिए भाई टेस्ट टेस्ट
वाला टेस्ट को तो हम वैसे भी हां अब इसमें
तुम नोट कर लो यार नॉट करके और टेस्ट लगा
दो यहां पे मैनुअली तो टेस्ट वाले को हटा
दो भाई ले है ही नहीं एक आया एक आया टेस्ट
वाले को अगर हटाया तो चलो एक आया कुछ है
क्या
अ
नथिंग नथिंग इसके अंदर कुछ की थोड़ी ना है
कुछ की नहीं है है ना वहां पे हमें की मिल
गया था तो हमने कर दिया कि चलो भाई कर
देते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं तो हमें वी
डोंट वी डिंट अ वी डोंट गेट एनीथिंग तो इस
तरीके से आप सर्च आउट कर सकते हैं ठीक
है चलिए यहां पे नीचे आ जाते हैं नीचे आ
जाते हैं नीचे आ जाते हैं यहां पे भी कुछ
मिले हैं डॉर्क फाइल नेम कुछ नहीं मिला
यहां पे फाइल नेम कंपोजर जेसन यहां पे
हमें जसन का एक रिजल्ट मिला है तो दिस कैन
बी
गुड यह मेरा ब्राउजर डिफॉल्ट कम है इसलिए
कम में खुल जा रहा है मैं यहां
firefox.exe
पाथ क्लिफा लुकिंग फॉर फाइल नेम ा यिंग
पाथ क्वालीफायर फाइल नेम इक्वल
टूट फाल्स पॉजिटिव
थाय सॉरी य फल्स पॉजिटिव था ठीक है यहां
पर फाइल नेम कॉन्फिन पर छ रिजल्ट मिले
मुझे
सो कॉपी
लिंक
तो यहां पर मुझे छ रिजल्ट्स मिले हैं
लेट्स फाइंड आउट व्ट इ
दिस नॉट नॉट एनीथिंग कुछ खास है नहीं
हमारे पास ठीक है कोई बात नहीं और कोई
रिजल्ट है क्या एक रिजल्ट य फाइल नेम
डेटाबेस का मिला हमें लेट्स ट्रा टू चेक
आउट व्ट वी गट
यर
पाथ के लिए ठीक है पाथ अरे
भैया चलो यहां पर पाथ दे देते
[संगीत]
हैं लेट्स
सी यहां पे
सॉरी रिपोजिटरी में आई है डेटाबेस
इशू में कुछ नहीं पुल रिक्वेस्ट में देख
लेते हैं ऐड स्क्रिप्ट टू कन्वर्ट ल जसन
ठीक है व्हाट इज
दिस अ नथिंग नथिंग नथिंग नॉट मच ऑफ द इंफो
दैट वी नीड कुछ खास हमारे पास है नहीं
यहां पे सो चलेगा तो इस तरीके से आपके पास
रिजल्ट्स आ रहे हैं यहां पे आप फिर से
मैनुअली थोड़ा देखा देख देख सकते हैं एंड
यहां पे अगेन हमारा जो है बंद हो चुका है
सेशन थोड़ी देर के लिए इन एक्टिव रह हैं
और यह बंद हो जाता है सिक्योरिटी पर्पस के
लिए कोई बात नहीं वी लॉग इन अगेन हमारे
पास सारा जो चीजें सेव्ड है ऑलरेडी यहां
पे एंड
[संगीत]
दैट्ची
वेट कीजिए थोड़ा और देखिए गिट
ग्रबर गिट ग्रबर में आ जाते हैं यहां पर
इस तरीके से एंड दिस वन
स इंस्टॉल कैसे करनी
है वही है पथ इंस्टॉल रिक्वायरमेंट्स है
एंड इंस्टॉलेशन सिंपल ही है लग रहा है
मुझे जैसा गिट क्लोन वाला जो सिस्टम है
वही
है यस तो गिट क्लोन ही करना है तो लेट्स
क्लोन इट एंड लेट्स एग्जीक्यूट इट गेट
क्लोन पेस्ट ट्स इट गेट ग्रबर इज क्लोनिंग
सीडी गेट ग्रबर एलएस यहां पे अब आ चुके
हैं यहां पे अगेन यहां पे गाइज
रिक्वायरमेंट t एकटी है अगेन मुझे वही चीज
सेम चीज आपको करनी पड़ेगी रिक्वायरमेंट एक
के लिए बट यहां पे मैं देख लेता हूं
ज्यादा कुछ है क्या रिक्वायरमेंट एकटी में
कुछ खास तो नहीं है एंड आई थिंक मेरी
रिक्वायरमेंट्स ऑलरेडी कंप्लीट होगी आप
लोग इंस्टॉल कर लीजिएगा जैसे मैंने पहले
बताया था एंड यहां पे परमिशन दे देता हूं
सी मोड + x g
gr.ii है तो यहां पे
cat.com भी ड कर सकते बट हमारे पास पाच है
ही हम पाच को य पर कन्फर कर देते हैं
चलो य हमने कॉपी
किया इंसर्ट मोड ऑन कर दिया आई प्रेस करके
एंड यहां हमने एक्स की जगह पर हमें क्या
डाल देना है यह वाला सॉरी सॉरी
सॉरी य हमें एक्स की जगह पर हमें डालना है
यह वाला टोकन ठीक है तो हमने ये वाला टोकन
डाल दिया नाउ वी हैव अनदर टोकन जो कि हम
यहां पे कंफिल कर देते हैं दूसरा वाला यह
रहा दूसरा वाला टोकन हम यहां पे इसको डाल
देते
हैं
दैट्ची फोथ
टोकन ी हैव द फोर्थ टोकन एंड हमने यहां पे
इसको डाल दिया फोर्थ वाले को ठीक है भैया
य जितने टोकन आप डाल सकते हैं डाल दीजिएगा
उसी के थ्रू चन चेन करके ये थोड़े लेस
चांसेस होंगे आपके कि आपका एपीआई लिमिट जो
है वो रीच आउट होगी ठीक है तो और कहां गया
अरे भाई क्या कर रहे हैं यार कहां गया
टोकन ये
रहा तो यहां पे पांचों टोकन हमने ऑलमोस्ट
कन्फर कर दिया है
सॉरी अ व्हाट इज दिस व्ट इज दिस व्हाट इज
दिस हां
जी तो हमने यहां पे पांचों टोकेंस जो है
वो कंफिल कर दिए हैं एंड
दैट्ची लच हो गया बहुत बढ़िया यहां पे आप
लिमिट डेज यहां पे देख लिमिट द रिजल्ट्स
टू कमिट लेस देन ए एंड डेज ओल्ड ठीक है
भैया कोई बात नहीं यह आप सर्टिंग कर सकते
हो इसको यूज कैसे करना है गेट ग्राबर प
उसके बाद यहां पे कीवर्ड फाइल आपको मेंशन
करनी है जो कीवर्ड फाइल आप यूज करना चाहते
हैं तो इसके आप देखेंगे अगर तो कीवर्ड
फाइल ऑलरेडी यहां पे आपको मिल जाएगा देखिए
जैसे कीवर्ड वड लिस्ट है ना वर्ड लिस्ट तो
सीडी वर्डलिस्ट चलते हैं पहले ऊपर चल लेते
हैं ऊपर से देखते हैं यहां
पे कहां इस तरीके से तो सीडी वर्डलिस्ट
में चलते हैं एलस करेंगे तो यहां कीवर्ड्स
txt.gz
अ कीवर्ड t एकटी इज नॉट कमिंग
की वर्ड्स t एकटी लिख दो नहीं आ रहा है तो
कोई बात नहीं कीव t एकटी यहां पे लिख दिया
उसके बाद यहां पे हान क्य क्वेरी के लिए
तो हान क्य कर दिया हमने अब यहां पे आपको
क्वेरी में आपको डालना है देखो यहां पे
स्पेसिफाई योर क्वेरी तो माय र्ग तो यहां
पे मैं कर देता हूं
रैपिड रैपिड आर ए पी वाई डी रैपिड ठीक है
इस तरीके से कर दिया या टेस्ला कर दो जो
भी तुम्हें चाहिए टेस्ला का टेस्ला कर दो
अपना जो भी तुम्हारा टारगेट है वो लिख दो
मैंने रैपिड लिख दिया rapid.com भी लिख
सकते हो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है अगर तुम्हें
चाहिए कि rapid.com डाल दे तो आप
rapid.com भी डाल सकते हो
rapid.com चाहिए तो आप कर सकते हैं मॉनिटर
कर सकते हैं वर्ड लिस्ट अगर चाहना चाहते
हैं तो आप वर्ड लिस्ट भी डाल सकते हैं बट
हम यहां पे बेसिकली कीवर्ड्स यूज़ कर रहे
हैं यहां पे कीवर्ड्स में न के लगा के तो
हम कीवर्ड यहां पेया यहां पे हमने कर दिया
दैट इट ये करके और हम एंटर करेंगे और उसके
बाद हमें वेट करना पड़ेगा देखिए यहां पे
ये सर्चिंग कर रही है यहां पे सर्चिंग
चालू है इसकी गेट रिपोजिटरी पांच टोकन
हमने डाले
हैं यह स्टार्ट कर चुका
है तो इट विल कीप लुकिंग फॉर सम सेंसिटिव
रिपोजिटरीज जहां पर कुछ सेंसिटिव अगर कुछ
मिल जाता है तो आपको यह लाकर दे देगा ट्स
ल सो लेट्स
सी ा के वाउचर्स अभी अवेलेबल है नहीं भाई
हमारे पास इसलिए आपको नहीं मिल पा रहे हैं
मार्केट से आउट ऑफ स्टॉक चला जा रहा है
बारबार बहुत डिमांड है
इसलिए कुछ कुछ देर यह स्लिप करेगा ताकि
आपको वो एपीआई लिमिट वाली प्रॉब्लम ना आए
तो यहां पर इसलिए आपको थोड़ा सा यह वेट
करा रहा है स्लिप मोड में ए देन अगेन से
यह स्टार्ट करेगा क्वेरी
करना ठीक
है देन यू विल गेट द
रिजल्ट्स
देखो स्लिप के बाद अगेन अगेन एपीआई लिमिट
वाली आ गई
प्रॉब्लम देखो एपीआई लिमिट इस पर्टिकुलर
टोकन के लिए तीनों टोकन के लिए लिमिट आ गई
है य पर ऊपर तो नहीं आया था बट इनके लिए आ
चुका है यह ठीक
है अगेन इट विल
वेट मजा आ रहा ना भाई कैसा लग रहा
है अगेन इट
रिंग करंग रिंग
धन्यवाद भाई लोग धन्यवाद चलिए शेयरिंग
करते हो कि नहीं भाई सेशन को यह बता दो
यार आप लोग शेयरिंग करते हो कि
नहीं 92 लाइक्स है 100 हो जाएंगे अभी
पॉसिबल पॉसिबल है 100 होंगे 92 लाइक्स है
यार 100 चलो यहां कुछ तो मिला पॉसिबल गल
टोकन फाउंड देखा पॉसिबल गल फायरवे और मैप
टोकन फाउंड पॉसिबल स्ट्राइप लाइव सीक्रेट
की फाउंड ऐसा है
क्या
एसके लाइव
ओके देख लेते देखते
हैं ओके
धन्यवाद यह देख पॉसिबल ग य पॉसिबल इसलिए
लिख र क्योंकि जरूरी नहीं 100% सही होगा
मतलब फल्स पॉजिटिव भी हो सकते हैं आपको
मैनली वेरीफाई करना पड़ेगा जैसे मेरे पास
एक चीज आ गई य
पर यह वाली आ ना पॉसिबल स्ट्राइप लाइव
सीक्रेट की फाउंड वाली र यूआरएल है और यह
टोकन है यह रिपोजिटरी यूआरएल है इस पर र
यरल प क्लिक करता हूं
मैं ओपन क्यों नहीं हुआ
एफ ए1 से मैं फुल स्क्रीन से बाहर आ जाता
हूं एंड एडब्ल्यू एस टोकन फाउंड तो एड्स
वाले पे चलो एक बार देख लेते हैं यहां पर
र वाली है इस पर क्लिक करते हैं पट ओ माय
गॉड गाइस देखा नॉट फाउंड भाई न फाउंड बच
[संगीत]
गया किसी ने रिपोर्ट कर दिया है इन्होने
हटा दिया उसको नॉट फाउंड कर दिया यह देखो
यह होती है खास
बात किसी ने बेचारे ने हटा दिया इस
ओके ी गट
समथिंग और टाइम देना होता है
भाई एक्सएल फाइल थी यार मजा आ जाता कुछ
होता तो सच में यहां पे कुछ है क्या
पॉसिबल एडब्ल्यू एस यह भी नॉट फाउंड है ह
है यार नॉट फाउंड
ग्रेट अ
राइट कुछ और मिलता है तो ठीक
है पस पस यह तो अवेलेबल है व्ट इज दिस
गाइस लेट अस सी लेट्स सर्च फॉर रैपिड आर ए
प वाई
डी डॉट नेट अरे कुछ है कि नहीं रैपिड गलत
वो दे दिया ना यार यह वाला यह वाला रेजे
ये मैचिंग करके दे दिया एक्चुअल रैपिड का
कुछ है नहीं इससे लेना देना बट ठीक है यार
एक्सेस की कुछ है
क्या एक्सेस की आईडी यह रही यह रही
एडब्ल्यू एस एक्सेस की आईडी एडब्ल्यू एस
सीक्रेट की एक्सेस की आईडी एंड सीक्रेट
एक्सेस की बकेट माय बकेट सांबा यहां पर आ
चुका है यहां पे एंड आईडी यहां पे आप
इसमें बेसिकली यू कैन गेट एक्सेस टू दिस
बकेट काइंड ऑफ बट ये है किसके लिए
यार सर्विस किस चीज की हैय बट लेट्स सी
तुम्हें मिला कुछ
[संगीत]
भाई पढ़ो बक क्राउड का यार पता चल जाएगा
बक क्राउड बताया उन्होंने कैसे बनाना होता
है बहुत सिंपल होता है यार तुम्हारा जो वो
प्रोफाइल है वही है बस वही है ऑलरेडी ईमेल
तुम्हें मिल जाती है वो तुम्हारे प्रोफाइल
के उसके हिसाब से देख र एक्सेस की मिल रहा
है यार क्या है
यह ल्ड सीवी कंपनी कौन सी है भाई य यह
वाली एक मिली है बट यह रैपिड की नहीं लग
रही है
मुझे कंट्रोल एड
कॉ लेट्स फाइंड किसी के भी हो कहीं कुछ हो
बुकिंग क्या बुंग कॉ नहीं यार बुंग कॉ की
कैसी
होगी बुकिंग कॉ बुंग कॉ यह सारे बुंग क है
क्या
भाई ओ
भाई हां
[संगीत]
हां यह बुकिंग ड कॉ से रिलेटेड चीजें मुझे
मिली है
भाई ओहो यह बुकिंग कॉ का है क्या बग बाउटी
प्रोग्राम बंगड कॉ का बग बाउटी प्रोग्राम
है क्या देखो जरा जल्दी बताओ मुझे तुम लोग
कोई बता यार booking.com का बग बाउटी
प्रोग्राम है कि नहीं जल्दी
देखो एडब्ल्यू एस
की
अ होटल्स होटल्स ड सीएसबी ये तो मुझे वही
लग रहा है
भाई
ओके रिपोर्ट कर दीजिए रिपोर्ट करना बनता
है मुझे लगता है
इसको मैं इस ल कोभी मैं रख रहा हूं अभी आई
विल नॉट बी क्लोजिंग दिस आई विल बी कीपिंग
इट मैं देखूंगा एक बार ट्राई करके बुकिंग
कॉ
बुकिंग कॉम बग बाउटी लेट्स
सी यह तो हैकर न प लग रहा है
मुझे अरे नो सच नो नो कैसे बोल दिया भाई
यह देखो book.com अवेलेबल है भाई ये दिख
रहा तुम्ह यह हैकर वन प हैय बुंग क
रिवॉर्ड देते हैं ये मतलब इनको भी रिपोर्ट
कर ये ब उनसे रिलेटेड है ना यार क्योंकि
मुझे तो लग रहा है रिलेटेड है 100% बिकॉज
ये होटल से रिलेटेड ही है आईडी यहां पे
ठीक है आउटपुट में सोर्स क्रेडेंशियल बकेट
नेम माय बकेट सांबा बट यह बकेट है क्या
ठीक है बकेट बीय सी बी यू सी केई टी बकेट
एक ही है क्या एक
दो हा
तीन बकेट
स्थ अ
सा ये है वी कैन रिपोर्ट इट चलो मैं सेशन
के बाद इसको रिपोर्ट कर देता हूं एक बार
मैं इसका इंपैक्ट थोड़ा देख लेता हूं कि
मैं इसके बकेट में लॉगइन कर पा रहा हूं
मैं बकेट का अगर एक्सेस कर पा रहा हूं तो
मैं रिपोर्ट कर दूंगा ठीक है जैसे ये बकेट
है अगर एक्सेस कर पा रहा हूं ये बकेट होटल
bing.com से रिलेटेड है तो आई विल रिपोर्ट
इट आई विल कीप इट एज एज इट इज मैं इसको
अभी कुछ छेड़छाड़ नहीं करूंगा मैं इस
यूआरएल को क्लोज नहीं करूंगा मैं इसको अभी
रहने देता हूं ठीक है बाकी चीजें मैं
क्लोज कर देता हूं एंड यहां पे ही मैं
सेशन को भी एंड कर देता हूं ठीक है आज का
सेशन यहीं पे एंड कर देते हैं बाकी मैं
इसको थोड़ा सा देखता हूं मुझे थोड़ा सा
टाइम लगेगा बकेट को एक्सप्लोइट कर देते
हैं बाकी मैं आपको बताऊंगा टेंशन मत लो एक
बार एक्सप्लोइट करके देखता हूं अगर
एक्सप्लोइटेबल होगा एंड होटल booking.com
से रिलेटेड होगा देन वी विल रिपोर्ट एंड
देन आई विल लेट यू नो कि रिपोर्ट क्या करा
है किस तरीके से करा है सब कुछ बताऊंगा
मैं ठीक है बट पहले अभी थोड़ा वेट कर लेते
हैं ठीक है जो होगा देखा जाएगा बिल्कुल
सही बात है ये सही है है ये पल्लब बोलता
है जो होगा देखा जाएगा बिल्कुल सही बात है
बग बाउटी में रिपोर्ट मारो जो होगा देखा
जाएगा चलिए तो
दैट्ची जें मिली कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग उसका ना
मिलकर कुछ और ही मिल गया भाई तो ये अच्छी
बात है मतलब अगर आपको मतलब कुछ और भी मिल
जा रहा है कोई ऐसी प्लेटफॉर्म का ऐसी
टारगेट का जो ऑलरेडी बग बांटी प्रोग्राम
में चलता है तो आप उसके भी कुछ रिलेट कर
लो कि उससे रिलेटेड है क्या किससे रिलेटेड
है तो booking.com से है तो अगर वैसा ही
है तो मारो ट उस पे जरूरी नहीं है रैपिड
पे मारो भाई ठीक है समझ में आ
गया इंटरेस्टिंग मजा आया ना ऐसे होती है
भाई चलिए यह स्लीपिंग 50 सेकंड का स्लिप
ले लिया ताकि 50 सेकंड के बाद यह करेगा अ
ये समझ में आ रहा
है यहां पर एडब टोकन यहां पर एक और मिला
इसको यह क्या
है हाउसेस एक्टिव मर्चेंट वी बाई वी बाई
हाउसेस ये क्या है भाई वी बा हाउसेस कुछ
है क्या य बाय हाउसेस अरेरेरे यह भी कंपनी
है इनका कोई सिक्योरिटी प्रोग्राम है
क्या दे बग बाउंट
प्रोग्राम कांटेक्ट कुछ कांटेक्ट तो है
नहीं वी बाय
हाउसेस इसका भी कुछ तो मिला ही है मुझे लग
रहा है व बाय हाउसेस बग बांटी
लेट
सी प्राइवेसी पॉलिसी क्लिक हाउस है वि
नहीं ऐसा कुछ नहीं है प्रीसी पॉलिसी
में कंट्रोल एफ बग
बाउंटीज
डिस्क्लोजर
रिस्पांसिबल नहीं है डिस्क्लोजर नहीं
है रिवर्ड नहीं इनका कुछ प्रोग्राम ऐसा
नहीं है बट ठीक है कोई बात नहीं नहीं है
तो कोई बात नहीं कुछ मिलेगा कुछ है क्या
कुछ इसमें ये भी तो देख लेते
हैं ओ हो हो
हो 2014 का है ये तो यार काफी काफी पुराना
है ये बट ठीक
है हेडिन बहुत सारी क्रेडेंशियल लीकेज है
यहां पे वर्किंग क्रेडेंशियल ये देखो
लॉगइन पासवर्ड भी दिया हुआ है
यूआरएल का अभी पता नहीं
हमें कौन सा ये ऑथराइज नेट लॉगइन पासवर्ड
एक्सेस
एसएमएस लेस लॉगइन यूजर नेम ये देखो
पासवर्ड क्या दिखा है पासवर्ड क्या लिखा
है यह पासवर्ड देखो एनड एआई पासवर्ड क्टी
123 ओ माय
गॉड बनवाया देख रहे हो
भाई एपीआई की बिट एपीआई की बहुत सारी
चीजें लीकेज भाई यहां तो शिट मैन गट अ
डिफरेंट लट ऑफ लट ऑफ बंच ऑफ इंफो
हियर
ओ चलो इसको फिलहाल इसको भी रहने देते हैं
एक लोकेशन इसको ओपन करके रखते हैं इस और
एक वो वाला कहां गया ये वाला है ना ठीक है
दैट्ची यहां पे बक क्राउड प हमने रिपोर्ट
भी किया था एक छोटा
सा जो मुझे बहुत डाउट है इसका कुछ देख
लेते हैं कुछ रिप्लाई आया क्या कुछ
रिप्लाई आया नहीं है यहां पे जब भी कोई
रिप्लाई आएगा आ वि आई विल लेट यू नो गाइस
ओके ट्स इट तो ये आप यूज कर सकते हैं गेट
ग्राबर को इसकी तरीके से ही एक और टूल है
जिसको आप यूज कर सकते हैं ऑटोमेशन के लिए
ट्रफल हॉग ट्रफल हॉग यह वाला भी टूल है
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग टूल है यह भी कुछ उसी
तरीके से काम करता है जिस तरीके से आप सोच
रहे हैं जनरली क्या करता है यह देख लो
यहां
पे फाइंड लीक्ड क्रेडेंशियल ठीक है बस और
कुछ भी नहीं है ट्रफल हॉक का यही काम है
इस तरीके से एक रिपोजिटरी के लिए आप फाइंड
आउट कर सकते हो कोई भी चीज अगर रिपोजिटरी
के अंदर मिलती है तो आपको ट्रफल लग जो है
फाइंड करके दे देता है कुछ इस तरीके से
इसके यूज केसेस आपको यहां पे नीचे आएंगे
तो दिख जाएगा कुछ इस तरीके से कि स्पेशली
गिट हब रिपोजिटरी के लिए कोई चीज फाइंड
करनी है या वैसा कुछ तो आप उसके लिए आप
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हो आप देख सकते हो यहां
पे आप दे सकते हो ठीक है इसको इंस्टॉल
करने का क्या तरीका है भैया यहां देख
लीजिए
इंस्टॉलेशन का तरीका यहां दे रखा होगा ये
गिट क्लोन कर लीजिए ट्रफल हॉग में जाइए गो
इंस्टॉल कर लीजिए
दैट्ची पे इसको मैं क्लोज कर देता हूं
लेट्स गेट आउट हियर अ गेट क्लोन अ गेट
क्लोन कर दिया हमने एंड वी विल पेस्ट हियर
एंड ट्रफल हॉक को क्लोन कर लेते
हैं ठीक है एंड यहां पे चलते हैं सीडी
ट्रफल हॉग एंड यहां पे एलस करते हैं
requirement.txt है क्या इसमें भी अ नो
रिक्वायरमेंट गो इंस्टॉल तो यहां पे गो
इंस्टॉल करेंगे इट विल गेट इंस्टॉल्ड
इंस्टॉल है क्या ओके ठीक है यहां पे ट्रफल
हॉग कमांड डालेंगे हान h एंड ट्रफल हॉग
विल बी लॉन्च्ड अब यहां पे अलग-अलग
सर्विसेस के ये लीक्स क्रेडेंशियल फाइंड
करता है जैसे गट के करता है गिट हब के
करता है गट लब के करता है फाइल सिस्टम s3
जीसीएस ये सारे ये करता है ठीक है ट्रेविस
हरका तो मुझे अभी गिट हब से मतलब है तो
इसका क्या मैं डालूंगा इस तरह से गिट हब
का देखो ना यहां पे क्या किस तरीके से
करना है गिट अप के बाद यहां पे फ्लैग्स
डाल देना है बस जो भी फ्लैग्स है वो डालिए
तो मतलब मेरे कहने का मतलब है ट्रफल हॉग
गिट हब देन हान h से आएगी कि हेल्प फाइल
हां जी देन अब हेल्प फाइल आ गई गिट हब
वाली ठीक है
तो फ्लैक्स डाल देने यहां पे जो भी फ्लैग
डालना है डाल दो भाई यहां पे
अ टोकन अग डालने है टोकन गिट अप टोकन हाइन
एफन टोकन गिट अप टोकन कैन बी प्रोवाइडेड
विथ द एनवायरमेंट ल गिट टोकन तो आप गिट अप
टोकन जो है आप हाईफा न टोकन इज इक्वल टू
कोई भी टोकन जो है आप लगा सकते हो जो टोकन
लगाना चाहते हो लगा सकते हो ठीक है उसके
बाद यहां पर सिंपल सा हान आई इंक्लूड पाथ
है एक्सक्लूड पाथ है यहां पे देन यहां
पे हां ट्स इट खत्म तो मुझे क्या करना है
एक रिपोजिटरी को मैं स्कैन कर सकता हूं
इसके थ्रू ये इसकी खासियत है ठीक है तो
मैं यहां प गेट अप किया यहां पे एंड यहां
पे इसकी एक हेल्प फाइल प आ जाते हैं ट्रफ
लॉक पे एंड लेट्स सी हाउ वी कैन गेट अ गेट
रिपोजिटरी
तो इस तरीके से गिट अप किया सॉरी सॉरी
सॉरी यहां से गिट अप किया यहां पे हान फफ
रेपो दिया और रिपोजिटरी का पाथ दे दिया
ठीक है भाई जो भी रिपोजिटरी का पाथ है वो
दे दो तो मैं यहां पे क्या कर देता हूं
हाइन हाइन रेपो एंड रिपोजिटरी का पाथ
जिसको हमें स्कैन करना है तो हमारा जो
टारगेट है उसी को हम स्कैन कर लेते हैं ना
कोई भी रिपोजिटरी उठा लेते हैं
[संगीत]
तो यहां प हमने सर्च किया था रड नेट रड n
ये इससे रिलेटेड कोई रिपोजिटरी है मान लो
तो इसको हम स्कैन एक बार सर्च कर लेते हैं
पहले . n को कोई रिपोजिटरी जो इससे
रिलेटेड आती है जैसे इससे रिलेटेड
रिपोजिटरी ये तीन रिपोजिटरी आ गई एमपी को
ग्लेस ये वाला ग्लेस वीवीसी जो भी है
व्हाट एवर ये वाली एक रिपोजिटरी आ गई ये आ
रहा है कनेक्ट टू एनेट कैरेक्टर्स ठीक है
यहां प कुछ है क्या कुछ है कुछ खास तो
नहीं मिला मुझे
ओके कोड मिल रहा है यहां पे ड नेट से
रिलेटेड इसमें कोई भी एक रिपोजिटरी उठा
लेते हैं जैसे ये पायल पत्रा का यह है
रैपिड पेमेंट सिस्टम ठीक है तो ये
रिपोजिटरी को उठा लिया हमने एंड यहां पे
हम इसको क्या कर लेंगे कॉपी कर लेंगे वी
विल कॉपी इट एंड यहां पे हम इस रिपोजिटरी
को पेस्ट मार देते हैं हमने इस रिपोजिटरी
को पेस्ट मार दिया हान रिपो लगा के अब
हमारा नेक्स्ट टारगेट क्या है नेक्स्ट
क्या है
हमारा यह कीवर्ड लगा सकते हैं ओनली
वेरीफाइड हान एफन ओनली हाइन वेरीफाइड तो
जो ओनली वेरीफाइड वाले हैं वही आएंगे हान
एफन
ओनली हान वेरीफाइड तो वेरीफाइड रिजल्ट्स
आपको मिल जाएंगे टोकन आप मेंशन कर सकते
हैं गिट टोकन आप दे हान टोकन से तो हान आन
टोकन दे देते हैं भैया इज इक्वल टू टोकन
ना देके फिर क्या फायदा टोकन दे देते हैं
बढ़िया रहेगा ज्यादा नाटक नहीं होगा तो
मैं यहां प एक टोकन दे देता हूं यहां पे
ये मैंने टोकन कॉपी किया यहां पे पेस्ट कर
दिया इतना यह कमांड इतना आप लोगों को समझ
में आया जल्दी बता
दीजिए जल्दी बता दीजिए इतना कमांड जो है
समझ में आया आप लोगों
के समझ में आया कोई बात नहीं
चलिए अरे भाई
पे हमें कुछ मिला नहीं है वेरीफाइड
सीक्रेट्स कुछ नहीं भी मिला अनवेरीफाइड
सीक्रेट्स जीरो है यहां पे फिनिश स्कैनिंग
सब कुछ हो गया हमें कुछ मिला नहीं यहां पे
स्कैनिंग वगैरह हो गई है अगर कुछ होगा
वेरीफाइड सीक्रेट्स वगैरह कुछ भी मिलेगा
तो ये आपको यहां पे दिखा देगा बस एज सिंपल
एज दैट ठीक है सिंपल आपको यहां पे कमांड
देना है एंड आपको चला देना है बस सिंपल
काम खत्म हो गया इस तरीके से कुछ होगा
मिलेगा आपको ये प्रोवाइड कर देगा राइट इट
बहुत सिंपल सा फंडा है कुछ नहीं है आपको
टफ लॉक गिट हब हान ो गिट के लिए गिट लगा
दीजिएगा रिपोजिटरी दे दीजिएगा जो एक
पर्टिकुलर रिपोजिटरी को सिर्फ स्कैन करना
है सब नहीं करना है तो आप ट्रफल लक का यूज
कीजिए काफी बढ़िया है ठीक है उसके बाद
यहां पर ओनली वेरीफाइड टोकन मेंशन कर
दीजिएगा ट्स इट एस सिंपल एस दैट ठीक है
चलिए एस बकेट वगैरह यह सभी चीज कर रहे हैं
आप इस टूल को थोड़ा एक्सप्लोर कीजिएगा मैं
आपको एक टास्क दे देता हूं सभी के लिए
देयर इज अ टास्क टास्क क्या
है टास्क क्या है चूज अ टारगेट चूज
अ
टारगेट डू मैनुअल गेट हब रिकन टू फाइंड
सीक्रेट्स
ठीक है मैनल गेट हब रिकन करना है
सीक्रेट्स फाइंड करने के
लिए
यूज टूल्स
लाइक गिट डरकर और गिट
रब सॉरी और ट्रफल
हॉग फॉर
ऑटोमेशन फॉर ऑटोमेटेड
रिकॉन ठीक है ऑटोमेटेड रिकॉन के लिए ये
करना है ठीक है
एंड रिपोर्ट द वनबिल इफ यू फाउंड इफ यू
फाउंड
सम ठीक है समझ में आ
गया सर बब शुड एक्टिवेशन वीडियो नहीं
अपलोड करी
वही तो बोलता हूं चेक किया करो ना यार
वहां थोड़ा तभी तो मिलेगा ऑलरेडी अपलोडेड
है भाई मेरे ठीक है यह टास्क है टारगेट
चूज करना है मैनुअल गिट अप रिकॉर्न करना
है फाइंड सीक्रेट्स के लिए गिट अप रिकॉर्न
वाले जो मैनुअल चीट शीट्स या फिर बोल सकते
हैं डॉक लिस्ट है वो मैं अपलोड कर दूंगा ए
ए पे एंड टूल्स गिट ड्रकर का यूज कर लीजिए
या गिट ग्राबर यूज कर लीजिए एंड देन आपको
ऑटोमेटेड यूज करना है राइट
दैट्ची है एक चीज और मैं आपको बताना चाहता
हूं ट्स अ लास्ट ऑ अपॉर्चुनिटी फॉर यू
डिस्ट फॉरसिस की हमारी जो लाइव ट्रेनिंग
लॉन्च हुई है जो 27 जनवरी से स्टार्ट हो
रही है 5 दिन के बाद से इसमें सिर्फ और
सिर्फ चार सीट्स अब बचे हैं ओनली फोर
सीट्स आर अवेलेबल आपको क्या करना है आपको
इस पे आना है de.com
digitalf5 में भी आपको लिंक प्रोवाइड कर
दे रहा हूं आप चैट वाले लिंक पे जाइएगा
एंड आराम से उसपे मैंने पिन कर दिया है
लिंक को आप उस पिन लिंक पे जाइएगा सारी
डिटेल्स चेक आउट कर लीजिएगा एंड आप इनरोल
कर सकते हैं 50 सीट्स थे जिसमें से 46
सीट्स ऑलरेडी फिल हो चुके हैं फोर सीट्स
आर रिमेनिंग ओनली यू कैन गो एंड यू कैन
एनरोल 27 से स्टार्ट हो रही है चार सीट
जैसे ही फुल होंगे खत्म हो जाएगी आपकी
इनरोलमेंट तो यू हैव द लास्ट चांस टू गेट
दैट ट्रेनिंग ठीक है इतने कम पैसों में
चलिए यहां तो हो गया यहां पे मैं इसको
क्लोज कर देता हूं एंड आई एम शटिंग डाउन
दिस
मशीन ओके मैं शट डाउन ठीक है अभी मैं शट
डाउन कर देता हूं फिलहाल के लिए बाद में
देखते
हैं श डन हैवन एच नाउ वी हैव क्लोज इट
दैट्ची
ठीक है टस इट चलिए ओके गाइस आई थिंक कि
आपके लिए सेशन इंटरेस्टिंग रहा होगा आप इस
सेशन को अपने दोस्तों के बीच शेयर जरूर
कीजिएगा जितना शेयरिंग कीजिएगा उतना ही
हिम्मत मेरे अंदर और उतनी बढ़िया क्वालिटी
कंटेंट आपके लिए सो ट्स ल फॉर टुडेज सेशन
गाइस थैंक यू सो मच
फॉर जॉइनिंग द सेशन नेक्स्ट सेशन में जरूर
आइएगा नेक्स्ट क्लास में और भी धमाकेदार
अभी चीजें होने वाली है अभी तो शुरुआत है
भाई सभी को गुड नाइट एंड विश यू ऑल अ
हैप्पी दिवाली
धन्यवाद